Nope.
Well,
Joe Rogan experience.
She's my favorite.
Mr Antonopoulos now you prefer
to not go buy bitcoin Jesus.
Is that correct? I do. I don't
like the end date of that story.
It doesn't turn out so
good for it comes back.
Well that's one version because the
problem with the Jesus story, right?
He comes back and then you don't
hear from him again. I quit him.
What the fuck happened there?
The guy comes back from the dead after
three days and then nothing. You know,
I even,
so the tortured to death part for,
for poking a steak at the big bad bear
of the Roman Empire is a bad enough story
as it is. I don't want to emulate any
part of that. Thank you. I agree with you.
Also the misuse of magic.
I mean to have like all that power and
to just like work on wine. You know,
I'm turning water into wine and
walking on water and stuff like that.
Like it seems like some other
things could have been done. Oh,
perhaps combining those two,
walking on wine,
they go like converting the
entire Sea of Galilee into wine.
I would have been a Shitty, awesome. Uh,
that would have been rude as fuck to all
those fish that live in there though.
It's just marinate them. It can be thrown
off to the grill right away by gas.
Delicious.
They didn't have refrigeration back then.
We're getting way off topic way early.
For those of you who don't know,
Mister Antonopoulos is
an expert in Bitcoin,
in digital currencies,
in what is most likely going to be,
in my opinion,
the future of economics.
I really do believe that this is not just,
I think what we're seeing
right now is not just a trend.
I think what we're seeing right now is
the beginnings of what will eventually be
a realization of what
I think people don't,
people don't need this third party system.
They don't need banks. They don't need,
well we need is,
we need to figure out some sort of a
way to exchange goods and services with
each other and to keep track of like what
things costs and right now we're doing
it with money and right now
we're doing it with money.
That's like somehow or another being
controlled by the World Bank being
controlled by the national
or the Federal Reserve.
And most people agree that that sucks,
that, that that system is not a,
it's not a fair or
equitable system and uh,
you're working very hard to try to alert
people about bitcoin and spread the
word. And I think you're
doing a pretty good job of it.
I think that the word
is getting out there.
I don't think I really need
to do much. Uh, that's,
that's the wonderful thing about marketing
or trying to talk about something
that's actually useful. Like if I
was selling hydraulic fracturing,
I'd have to really try hard to persuade
people that it's not fucking up the
environment.
But with bitcoin it's really useful money.
It can solve a lot of problems.
All I have to do
is introduce the concept and young
people, you know, the idea, hey,
we're going to put money on
the Internet. What, what?
Of course we're going to put money
on the Internet. Makes perfect sense.
And we're going to make it cold bowl and
it's going to work without borders and
it's going to be instantaneous.
Well, uh, of course, you know,
how come we haven't done that yet?
Um,
and so it's an easy idea to sell.
Well the system,
if for folks who haven't heard your
earlier podcasts that we did and they not
familiar with what bitcoin is,
just give them a brief description
of how the bitcoin system works.
So at a very basic level,
bitcoin is internet money.
It's money that you can send like an
email. It's like Skype for money. Um,
you can create an account if you like.
It's kind of like an account,
but it's basically an application that
you download onto your phone or your
desktop.
And once you do that,
you have a bitcoin address and you can
send and receive bitcoin and it's a car
and currency works like a foreign
currency and you can convert dollars to
bitcoin and bitcoin to dollars impact.
But the,
the really cool thing is that you can
send bitcoin to anybody else in the world
in a matter of seconds
for almost no fees at all.
And if you do have to pay a fee,
it's like usually something like a third
of a penny and it has nothing to do
with how much you're sending
and in a few seconds cheaply,
securely all around the world,
instantaneous money. So it,
it takes money from a technology of
the 50s and it drags it into the 21st
century kicking and screaming.
It would just so we can get past this,
um,
just explain how it's created
and explain like how it's,
how it's controlled,
like how the,
the number of bitcoins is generated and
how this is not something that can be
fucked with the same way money is fuck
with today where they can just print
money and cause debt and
create a lot of problems.
Explain that.
So bitcoin is a decentralized peer to
peer network of money and that's a lot of
fancy words, but I'll relate it to
things that people are familiar with,
especially for younger generation and
things like bit torrent or Napster or
things like that where you run a piece
of software in your computer and that's
simultaneously using resources but
also sharing resources for others.
And the network is made up of everybody
running a bit of software on the
computer and coming together
in a collaborative way.
A bitcoin is money done that way.
So everybody runs some software and
the collaboration of everybody on the
network to run this software to secure
and verify all of the transactions that
is happening,
that also produces the currency and the
currency is produced at a predictable
rate.
So every 10 minutes,
25 bitcoin are created and the created
on the network by the network and they're
created through this,
uh,
kind of like a competition that
happens online with computing.
Power will go into too of that detail.
But the point is every toy,
every 10 minutes,
25 new bitcoin are created.
And then that happens for about four
years and then after four years,
the rate of new bitcoin is caught by half.
So when first started it was
50 bitcoins every 10 minutes.
Now it's 25 in the year 2016 it's
going to drop to 12 and a half.
Then it's going to go to six and a
quarter and it keeps reducing by half and
till eventually no more
bitcoin are created.
And if you do the math and you add up the
years and you keep dividing by two you
end up with about 21 million bitcoin and
most of them will be done in the first
decade.
But then that lasts small
percentage takes a very long time.
The last one is in the year 2141 if
you just project out by that point,
of course the world has changed,
but if you just run that equation
and so 21 million Bitcoin,
that's all you can ever have.
And the,
the interesting thing about that is
that it changes people's behavior.
If you know how much money is going to
exist in the system, you, you value,
it's differently. Like right now, if the
Federal Reserve had a meeting on Friday,
no one in the world except for the people
on the Federal Reserve Committee. No.
What's going to happen with money is
the Monday after you have no visibility.
They might say we're not going to print
another trillion dollars and all of the
money you have in your pocket
is now worth, you know, a
10th of a percentage less.
Or they might say we're not gonna print
anything next year and suddenly your
valley eat the value for money is
going to change. But with Bitcoin,
I can tell you exactly how much bitcoin
is going to be around two decades.
No. Now since you got
involved with good point,
what if any,
change in perception have you
seen in the public? Like the, the,
the initial idea of Bitcoin for a lot
of people was like, wait a minute,
what are you guys can't do? You
have digital. Like people like, hmm,
but now you're seeing more and more
people use it. Tiger direct uses it.
You could buy computers from them.
Does Dell use it now as well? Well,
Dell and more importantly,
the most recent announcement to about a
month and a half or two months ago was
paypal.
Paypal is now going full bitcoin.
They're going to offer a bitcoin
as a payment mechanism for paypal.
That's pretty intense,
which is a pretty huge,
as I did not expect that
was going to happen. I was,
I was thinking maybe in a year or two it
happened a lot faster than I expected.
That's pretty intense. That's paypal
and square of course. What is square?
The square is the little thing you stick
on top of an iPhone to swipe a card
with and they have square market. They've
been doing bitcoin now for six months.
Wow. And that's expanding. So in terms of
retail shopping, it's moving pretty well.
But you know, as you probably remember
from our previous discussions,
retail shopping isn't where
I think it's really powerful,
but it's great to see these advancements.
Um,
a lot of interesting things are happening.
The perception is also shifting. Uh,
at first, um, you know,
bitcoin was so obscure that the only
people who talk about it worth a complete
lunatic fringe likes the,
the nerds, the people.
No one understands that the party and in
any case they don't really talk to us.
So, um, so that's the, there was the
lunatic fringe. Now we've upgraded a,
now people think that bitcoin
is all about a drug dealers,
terrorists and pornographer.
So we're making some progress here.
How does that happen?
Well, you know, I mean,
what do you think the
media is going to focus on?
Do you think they're going to focus on
the fact that most bitcoin is charitable
giving donations and tipping
something you experienced too with,
with the donations to, um, uh,
to the address you showed to the
last show? A lot of that's going on,
but then also what's going on is things
like Silk Road and the media really
loves that kind of story.
You're not going to say, well,
people are raising charitable
donations on the Internet. No,
they're going to say people are buying
cocaine on the internets and that's a
much better headline.
So we went from completely obscure to
mostly negative press and now you're
beginning to see people say, yeah, you
know, there's more to it than that.
And I think the public perception is
gradually changing because primarily they
hear about it more and more in,
in a better context.
Yeah. We, we wound up sending thousands
of dollars to Justin wren who is a,
he's got this charity that it does,
um,
finding for the forgotten and it's
all about the pygmies in the Congo.
He lives in the Congo most of the year.
And, uh, all that came from bitcoin.
I just took the money from, from
bitcoin. I doubled it, you know, I,
whatever the people sent in from the,
the donations from the address that we
posted on the website and the web show,
uh, I took that and a
whatever they came up with,
I added the exact same amount and
we sent it to Justin. So I mean,
that money from bitcoin
donations want to deal, uh,
with a water issues that they have,
uh, digging wells, all sorts of things.
And he's going to be on the podcast
next week. So he'll explain to us,
but that's Bitcoin in action,
right?
Yeah. I, I've already done two or
three fundraisers with bitcoin.
There's a couple of favorite charities
that I support in a number of ways and I
found that the fact that it makes
it so easy for people to give and so
instantaneous and it's a way for them
to demonstrate why they love this
technology. A lot of people
will do it. So, um, and,
and a lot of people have been bugging
me to get you to take bitcoin on the
stores and take bitcoin on
various activities or maybe
even put a tip jar up for
your new comedy show. I heard,
I actually saw a trailer of that
comedy central would have to ask Tom
Comedy central to do that because a,
I did it through them,
this latest one. But yeah,
I'd be interested in
doing something like that.
I'm just right now I'm just super busy.
That's,
and it stops me from getting
a fully involved with this,
but I'm always fascinated and I love
watching other people adopt it as well.
Like a shooter. Jennings just had
a big ad online where he was, uh,
taking bitcoin for all of his new cds
and he was selling them old ones as well,
selling them all through bitcoin.
Yeah.
I've been to shoot her about
doing some, uh, some other
activities with bitcoin too,
so we'll see where that goes. Yeah.
Shooter loves it. He, you know,
he thinks bit coins a future and you know,
he didn't even know how to post the
other day were just talking about people
saying that Bitcoin,
you know,
hold onto your like people have this
idea of hold on your bitcoin and one day
you'll Cashman for $1 million
and he's like, no, hold on.
Your bitcoin and one day you'll
have bitcoin. Like you are needed.
You won't need the million dollars.
It won't, won't be valid. Like, well,
it'll be valid me.
I'm sure money's not going to go away,
but it'll also be just as valid.
And you know what you saying about paypal?
We're starting to see that.
Yeah, I think so. And, uh, you know,
you've got to think also about many
countries in the world where their own
currency is, is really bad. And, uh,
this represents a global currency
that may end up being more stable,
more valuable than their own currency.
So is it going to be more valuable
and more stable than the U s dollar?
Probably not for you know, at the
best case, decades if then if ever,
but there's 193 currencies out there.
Can it be more stable and more valuable
in the 30 of those probably is today and
50 of those within a few years.
So you're basically seeing this
revolution in international currencies.
We're not going to displace
the most successful currency
that the world has ever
seen over at night with something that at
five years old is a toddler technology.
Um,
but we can offer opportunities around
the world where their own currencies are
really,
really poor and,
and not very good for transnational
and cross border transactions at all.
Now what has been going on as far as like
the shift, cause I know that there's,
there's been a lot of volatility issues
where the price has gone up and down.
Things have moved around a lot.
Like has that in any way stabilized?
Um,
it's stabilized.
If by stabilize we could say that it's
gone down quite a bit and then it's kind
of stuck to around the three 50 to
$400 US dollar level for a while now.
Um, but you know, it, it depends
on what you do with bitcoin really.
There's, the volatility really affects
you if you're looking for an investment,
especially if you're day trading.
Bitcoin wishes about the stupidest thing
you can do because it behaves like a
penny stock on steroids,
right?
So a lot of people get into bitcoin
because they hear about the price and they
get this idea that this is a get
rich quick scheme, which it's not.
And they try their hand at day trading
with disastrous consequences because
you're talking about a very volatile
market with exchanges that are not
regulated and in various
countries around the world,
which have very little liquidity and
some pretty big professional traders who
are like sharks in the water were like
playing the market quite effectively and
taking all the newbies for a ride.
And so that's not,
I don't think that's a
valuable activity in bitcoin.
I think if you use it to
as a payments network,
accept bitcoin then converted to your
national car and see to restrict your
exposure.
So for example,
a Sasol tee shirt for $10 I'll price it
at a $10 I'll get $10 worth of bitcoin
and I'll convert it to $10 right away.
Now if next week the price
changes, doesn't matter. I've
already sold a tee shirt,
I've already got dollars in return,
I'm good.
I've opened up a completely new payment
channel without any of the risk. So,
so you can kind of get around that and,
and find ways to use it.
I don't really, you know, for some people
bitcoin can be a longterm investment,
but it's really dumb to day trade.
It's,
and that's where you get exposed
to most of that price volatility.
Isn't that an issue though of you're
selling things and cause of your selling
things online?
Like would you sell it like say if you're
selling mugs mug you have in front of
you, you're, you were selling
them for, you know, $10 American,
what would you,
$10 worth of Bitcoin?
Is that how you would factor it in?
Yeah, so let's say, um, today bitcoin is,
I actually don't know what the price
is right now, but I can look it up.
And so I can say what is
$10 worth in in Bitcoin?
And once I do that calculation,
I can figure out what the price
is and I can price the, um,
the sale. So for example,
I would say receive,
I would pick an amount in dollars,
say $10.
So $10 at the moment is 0.026 bitcoin or
26 point 18 millibitcoins thousands of
a big c.
I would just so the customer wouldn't
see this and the website will do this
automatically. So I'd put my mug
up, you'd click it, we say, okay,
$10 you put it in your cart,
you say checkout,
and it would just present
you with a QR code like this.
Now this is actually asking for
10 US dollars worth 26 millibits.
So if you tried to click
on this with your wallet,
it's going to tell you to pay the amount
of $10 10 US dollars equivalent in
bitcoin.
So the store does the
calculation automatically and
then when the bitcoin comes
in,
it gets bundled and at the end of the
day it gets converted to dollars or
sooner. If you have a lot of volume
and so you don't see any fluctuation,
price goes up, price goes down. It doesn't
matter cause you price it, you earn it,
you convert it.
Now when you do that though,
like if you were,
if you're a person that has
bitcoin and you're buying things,
you would wait until it's worth more
before you bought something, right? Yes.
So you wait until your bitcoins more
valuable or I'm thinking about buying
something,
but I want to hold on until big like that
seems to be a bit of an issue, right?
Yeah.
That's called a deflationary effect,
which means that if you have a currency
that is deflating where the value of the
currency is increasing over time, then
people will tend to hoard that currency,
hold onto it and not spend it right away
because they hope that it's going to be
worth more in the future. Um,
now in the case of Bitcoin,
we've had periods where
it's climbed in value,
so the hoarding instant gets strong.
We've had periods where it drops in value,
so people want to get rid of it.
All currencies have that.
Bitcoin has it a bit more of the
moment because it's volatile.
The hoarding is instinct.
You know,
it's funny because in the US we call it
the hoarding instinct in Asia that what
they call this savings,
which is an inconceivable
concept to most Americans,
like the saving grace for example in
Asia exceeds 20% in some countries and in
the u s it's a negative
0.2% or something like that.
So actually people increase their
debt every month instead of saving.
So it's also a cultural thing.
I think hoarding is seen
as a bad thing in a very,
very strong consumer society where you're
supposed to take care of the paycheck
and converted directly into plastic crap
from China as quickly as possible and
not keep pending all of it for the
future that that makes for a really good
black Friday. Right? That's
the attitude. So if you,
if you don't spend that seen
as a bad thing, I'll tell you,
once I started using Bitcoin,
I ended up saving more money.
I did become more frugal
with my purchases,
but honestly when I saw something
that was priced correctly and I wanted
something to buy,
I'd buy it.
I wouldn't wait another week for the
price to go up or down and start because
then again, at that point you're
back to j day trading. Right?
Well since it's gone with paypal,
you could pretty much buy,
there's a lot of things you can buy.
I mean,
I wouldn't say everything but many things.
When you go to buy things online,
do you view that paypal option at
checkout? Yeah, and to paypal vendors.
We'll turn off the bitcoin option yet,
but they will have the option to turn it
on overtime. As paypal rolls this out,
they just started it as a trial basis.
It's probably going to take, you know,
six months to a year before they role
as how it fully and then it's sounding
good,
mean 19 countries or have any paypal's
serves and the merchants will have to go
and turn it on. But you know, it
gives them another sales channel.
So the other nice thing about that
is that if you have a web store,
pay pal integration usually comes with it.
So turning on in your
paypal merchant account,
the bitcoin option makes your existing
web store bitcoin capable without you
having to change any of the code.
And that's a pretty big deal.
That is a very big deal. You surfing
totally unrelated over there? No,
I was trying to recover
my a big coin wallet.
We were talking about that
before the show. So he,
he got a new phone and his bitcoin wall
and for whatever reason didn't transfer.
Yeah. I mean I backed up all like,
you know, you get your phone,
you back up all your programs and
stuff before I sent, you know,
I sold my old phone and uh, didn't even
think about it. Redownloaded all my,
my apps on media automatically open
it up and it's like, oh, you know,
sign up or
use an existing user and try to put in,
there's an,
it's really hard to figure out.
That's why I was just trying to do is
going online and try to reset my password.
They won't let you reset your password
ever cause they don't keep passwords on
the websites. So it looks like I might've
just pretty much lost my wallet. Right.
It depends. I think, um, if you use the
application that we installed last time,
which was blockchain in full,
that created a web account,
the wet with it and if you put
your email address in there,
you can reset it fairly effectively so
you can send them a support message and
they can probably recover your wallet.
Yeah, that's what it looks like.
That's what I was doing just now where
I found out the email address I used,
but now I have to like fill out this
questionnaire with my Skype name and stuff
like that. It looks like they might want
to even interview me to see him. It's,
it's actually going to take a few days
and the reason it's going to take a few
days,
and I used to advise that company from a
security perspective is because what we
would do is we'd have hackers who
compromise people's GML account.
They found the fact
that they signed up for,
for bitcoin wallet and they'd use the
fact that they use our email address,
they trawl and find their wallets name
and a bunch of other information and then
they'd go to this website, tried to do
a reset and try to steal their money.
So we make it a bit harder.
You have to get a confirmation
through email, um,
so that people can't easily social
engineer and fish for your account.
But it seems like it's possible,
which is good to hear because
that's absolutely possible.
You should be able to recover your funds
and then all you have to do is then
connect the application
back to the website.
And that's the advantage of this hybrid
model where your wallet is on your phone
and you have complete control. The
website doesn't have access to it at all,
but it stores and encrypted backup online
so that as you see if you lose your
phone or, or drop your phone
in the toilet. Right, exactly.
If you have like $1 million with a bit
coin and your phone and it falls into the
toilet, that's yeah, that would be bad.
You shouldn't keep that much money on
your phone anyway. Uh, just like, I mean,
you have to treat your phone wallet
the same way you treat your wallet,
which is,
I don't carry my entire net worth in here.
I have a bit of petty cash in
here and the rest of my bitcoin,
I'm just like the rest of my us dollars.
I keep offline.
I keep it in another location.
One of them Floyd Mayweather type
ballers flex to walk around with a big
briefcase full of bitcoin. Well then you
can do some pretty cool demonstrations.
Uh, there's this investor in
Argentina who gathered a bunch of his,
his investment friends at a,
at a golf outing and set
them down at a table. Six,
six people who had, um, you know,
just some of them had just met with the
other people and had never done bitcoin
before. And he said, Hey, let
me show you how bitcoin works.
Download this application to your phone.
So they all did that and he said, okay,
well we're going to do is we're going to,
I'm going to send you some money
and we play hot potato. So you, you,
you receive it,
you wait and you send it to the person
next to you and then the person next to
you and then the person next
to you and I call it great.
We're going to move some bitcoin
around,
see how this works.
So since the first batch and the first
person looks at their phone and they just
received the quarter of a million dollars,
what a quarter of $1 million sent in a
matter of seconds for a third of a penny.
And then they're like, they're hand
shaking and they just swipe across,
send it to the next person,
quarter million dollars,
quarter million dollars
six times around the table.
Now you've done one and a half million
dollars worth of wire transfers for total
cost of less than 10 cents.
And it's back at the original owner.
And,
and the purpose of this demonstration
was there is no payment system on the
planet that could do what we just did.
Yeah.
But in the future you're going to get
screwed. Like the IRS. It's like, Hey,
it says here, you've shared a half million
dollars, we need half a million of,
you know. Well, yeah, that depends.
I mean like what's the IRS his take on
it and now there's some unique take on
what bitcoin actually is. They're not
treating him as if it's the regular money,
they're treating it for taxation purposes.
The way that we treat
a tradable commodity,
which means that if you buy bitcoin and
the price goes up and you sell bitcoin
and you make a game,
you have to pay capital gains tax.
And if you earn bitcoin by
selling products and services,
then you have to pay income tax.
Which to me is a very reasonable and
sensible way to treat it. So for example,
if I do a Gig and Europe and
I charge my clients in euros,
I'm going to pay income
tax on those years.
But if I hold those heroes for three
months and then I sell them, um,
and the price has gone up,
in the meantime,
I'm going to pay capital gains on the
difference between the price I bought them
or in the math and the price of solar.
So it works in exactly the same way at
the IRS doesn't go around really tracking
everybody's bank account, doing the psalms
and checking against your tax return.
That's not how it works.
The way it works is you make the
burden is on you to make an honest,
truthful and complete return.
And when you make an honest,
truthful and complete return, quite
honestly, they don't check it.
If they have reason to suspect where
they randomly sample that they do
statistical analysis and they,
they see the things don't add up,
then they're going to come and say,
okay, you said x, prove it right.
And they sh they flipped the burden
and now you have to show that this is
exactly what happened. Well,
they treat bitcoin the same way.
I make an honest,
truthful and complete tax return
to the best of my ability.
And I calculate my income based on
my invoices and things like that,
which I receive in Bitcoin and I calculate
my capital gains and I pay my taxes.
I mean,
it's really not complicated for me
and it's not complicated for the IRS.
And if they come audit me,
they're going to ask me, you know,
show us where this bitcoin came from.
A were wet and I can show up.
Is there any way,
I don't know if this is even possible,
but is there any way to simplify what
dollars to bitcoin actually stands for?
Because when you say
that one bitcoin is,
you know,
x amount of US dollars or
$1 is Baba, you know, in,
in digital points of Bitcoin,
that conversion is confusing to people.
Oh yeah. It's, it's, it's
really confusing. Yeah. That,
and I think that's an issue.
Yes. Sorry, that's an issue
with some folks when you know,
you talk about like getting involved
in bitcoin and they see the numbers and
they see the differentiation.
It's, it's problematic.
It gets, it gets in their head, they're
like, oh, what is it? How much is 0.1
it's, it's hard. It's hard enough to
go to Italy, order an espresso, right?
And pay 1,500 Lira.
And in your head,
you're trying to figure out how
much is 1,500 Lira and dollars.
That's already confusing enough for
most people because it involves the,
you know, higher order mathematics
of division, which, you know,
I can't do it in my head. I use a
calculator and when it comes to Bitcoin,
it's worse because when we
use bitcoin as the units,
because it's worth a lot more than $1,
all of the denominations
end up being fractions.
So at 0.026 for example,
is $10.
And that's even worse because most
people can't do fractional mathematics,
save their life.
Um,
so one solution to that is
to switch the unit of value.
So instead of talking about Bitcoin,
you talk about the middle of bits.
So it's easier to say it's
26 millibits 26. Okay,
26 for a t shirt. I can understand
that. That makes a lot of sense.
And when Bitcoin was at
about a thousand dollars,
then a middle a bit was a dollar.
So it was a lot easier cause then it
would have been 10 millibits for a $10 tee
shirt. And that makes a lot of sense.
Other people who've proposed bits,
which takes you more to
the Italian lira side,
which is a hundred
thousandth of a bitcoin.
And so at that point you're looking at,
you know,
5,000 or 10,000 for a t shirt. Um, so it,
it feels more like where you have bigger
numbers for smaller things like Italian
money,
but still better to do 5,000 bits,
which is a fraction of
a bitcoin for a coffee.
Then tried to do 0.0013 no
one can do that kind of math.
So really it's about what units do you
use for everyday conversation? Yeah,
no one can and no one wants to,
no one wants to be done.
We want like a dollar is
of this. Yes. You know,
I mean that's what people want.
I have the following simple rule of thumb,
which is that in any currency,
if you want to make it easy for people
and you can pick the currency units you
want, then a uh, a meal, a simple meal,
a sandwich,
a fast food meal,
a cup of coffee and a pastry should cost
between one and 100 of your units of
currency. Pick whatever units makes
it fall into the one to 100 range.
People are comfortable. The idea
of spending, you know, 10, 50, 60,
15 for a meal, a coffee, a pastry,
they're not comfortable with fractions.
They're not comfortable with
a very high numbers either.
Like spending 5,000 for a coffee
doesn't make sense, but you know,
spending 25 of your units for a coffee.
That makes sense.
So that's my rule of thumb
between one and a hundred.
Pick the unit that makes it fall in that
range. You why when bitcoin was created,
was it established that way?
Where one bitcoin to be such a large
amount of dollars? Well, it wasn't a,
here's the thing, when it
was just that, first of all,
for the first year and a half of bitcoin
had no dollar price at all because no
one was,
there was no market where it was being
actively traded so that you could
establish a price point.
The price of the moment,
say $350 comes from the fact that recently
someone was willing to give someone
$350 for their bitcoin. So
it's a market based system. Uh,
when Bitcoin was launched,
uh,
you could buy a thousand bitcoin or
even 10,000 bitcoin for a dollar.
Damn right? Yes. Should have bought
some nice clean fuck. So we have,
we have a, one of the most famous things
as the pizza event, and this was when a,
in the first year and a half when nobody
really had a price for, for Bitcoin,
a user called Laszlo,
uh,
online suggested buying pizza for bitcoin.
And this was like crazy talk.
Like,
I want to find a way to use my
bitcoin to buy something I want.
And there were no markets. That was
no one who was taking it. He said,
I want to buy pizza,
so I'm going to give bitcoin to someone
who's going to order pizza with a credit
card online and have it delivered
to my, to my, to my house.
I believe we talked about this on a
$10,000 pizza now or something like that.
It was a 10,000 bitcoin pizza.
Oh Jesus.
That's a three point $5 million pizza.
He bought two of them that
$7 million for two pizzas.
So the point is the
price has varied a lot.
Bitcoin used to be fractions of
a penny and now it's 350 bucks,
so we don't know where
the price is going in.
The creator couldn't know what's the
creator and those who are participating in
the early days thought was, it's probably
going to be worth very little now,
but over time if people adopt it
because there's a limited quantity,
it's value is going to go up.
So we're going to need to have
more units to break it down into,
so we can start talking about tens
of bitcoins and hundreds of bitcoins.
Then we'll talk about bitcoins, then we'll
talk about tenths, thousands, millions,
and it goes down to a hundred millions.
The smallest unit is called a Satoshi.
It's a hundred millions of a bitcoin,
eight decimal places.
That seems ridiculous.
It's a pennies. I hate
pennies. I don't know.
I don't even really like
Nicole's fucking nickel.
Everything should be dimes or nothing
by quarter.
And this is the difference between the
digital currency because this doesn't
have value right now.
So you don't use it in conversation.
If it did have value in the future.
So if it was worth a quarter, right,
then you'd use that and Toshi and
I'll give you a cup of coffee. Yes.
And if right,
at which point I'm a bitcoin
will be worth a lot of money.
Now you were just in New Zealand.
I did a tour of Australia and New Zealand,
a series of talks about bitcoin.
A is also a conference.
They're called bitcoin south
and New Zealand in Queenstown.
Now when you fly over there, you paying
for your airline tickets with bitcoin.
Um, to indirectly, yes. Into that.
First of all,
when I was flying to New Zealand's,
my cost was covered by
the conference organizer.
The conference organizer was paying
both me and for all of the expenses in
Bitcoin, all of the suppliers, the
entire conference was paid for.
And bitcoin where they can
pay directly in bitcoin.
They pay in bitcoin where they can,
they sell it,
get New Zealand dollars and they
pay New Zealand dollars. Um,
I also got sponsored to do a
couple of talks in Australia.
I got paid in Bitcoin for that.
When you were, oh, when you
were over in New Zealand,
did you look into the Kim Dotcom situation
and are you a m s you're smiling,
so you must be well aware of what's
going on with him over there.
I think, I mean, Kim Dotcom is, is,
is such a really great personality.
I mean he's,
he's larger than life. Um, and he,
he just has this tendency to poke a
stick in the eye of governments and he,
he often gets away with it
because governments tend to
overreact and break their
own laws going after him, which is
hilarious, right? Because they, they,
they ran through just rough shod over
their own judicial system to confiscate
his servers.
And then he fought them in court and
he won because they lost in court.
They had to return his servers
to him after three heres a,
because they had to illegally confiscated
them and Kimdotcom who was allegedly a
accused of copyright infringement,
they raided his house with about a hundred
paramilitary to style police officers
in the peaceful island of New Zealand
for God's sake and helicopters and
rappelling down from helicopters in the
middle of the night to serve a warrant
for copyright infringement. So I
mean, if that doesn't say overreach,
it's ridiculous.
That's clear that they're trying to say
some sort of a message and not just
send a message, but to scare him.
They're trying to bully him.
They're trying to write and bully anybody
else that would be brazen enough to
have similar
existence. And this wasn't a
New Zealand operation alone.
This was in conjunction with the FBI
and other organizations from around the
world. And it was a massive overreach
and they broke their own laws to do it.
And he turned around and robbed it and
rub their face in it because they'd
broken the law. They ended up
being the criminals first. So yeah,
I don't know where the states
prosecution is going on that,
but as with many cases like this,
there's a lot of up front,
you know,
big talk about how
they're bringing it down,
this great criminal and then all of the
charges fall apart when they tried to
present them in court.
Yeah. And there's, they're confiscating
all of his money to, right. Well,
they're trying to who
they have, I mean, he's a,
he's actually said that
he's broke now. He's, uh,
in some precarious situation because he
spent over $10 million in legal fees and
he, he actually generated some insane
amount of money since they released him.
We see in January, like $40 million with
him. I mean, he's a moneymaking machine.
The dude knows how to make
money. Right. But his, uh,
that whole mega upload
website and all that stuff,
because it's all that's all in
some serious trouble right now.
Yes, it is. Um, so yeah, I,
he obviously has nothing to do with,
with Bitcoin,
just just to be clear in case that's why.
Well,
why wanted to bring that up that you know,
here's a guy who maybe could possibly
benefit from moving as money,
at least a big chunk
of it in the big coin.
Well,
I mean if what he's doing is in fact
legal and if what the government is doing
is in fact a bullying him
outside the parameters of law,
then that might be a perfectly
justified stance. I mean,
I wouldn't recommend using pick
coin for criminal activities.
I don't think that's a
good advice for anyone.
Well, how legal noble of
you it, I wouldn't recommend
I, I don't, I don't think it's
right to, to sit here and encourage,
you know, illegal acts. But you know,
to talk about copyright infringements a
resulting in a helicopter raid and arms
military rate on someone's house in
the middle of the night. I think,
I think we have to really question
where is the justice in that time.
What exactly is going on with that case?
Well Copyright Infringement for folks
who are not completely informed on what,
what the whole upload situation is,
what w with kim.com [inaudible] website.
What he was accused of essentially is
that people would upload illegal downloads
of movies,
of songs and things along those lines.
So he wasn't even doing
copywriting Fritchman himself,
he was facilitating it
allegedly for others,
which is even once that removed from
a crime that is a civil crime against
property.
And I mean really talk about
an overreaction if that's
the standard of justice.
I have to ask.
Um,
what kind of armed helicopter response
should descend on Aig for fucking over a
million homeowners and stealing billions
of dollars during the mortgage crisis,
right?
How many,
how many helicopters should go down on
that case where you have actual victim?
So this is the real issue here,
which is that there are crimes
that result in mega victims.
Millions of people put out of their homes
losing a generation's worth of savings
and no one goes to jail.
Yeah,
that's a huge point.
It's a monster point and there's
a sanctioned fevery in that sense.
Did you get to see the, the thing
that came out today, uh, in Iraq,
that there's 50,000 ghost troops.
There's 50,000 troops that are receiving
checks that are human beings that don't
even exist. Yeah. They don't even exist.
And they're, they're getting checks.
Hello? Yeah. War has always been the
most profitable racket available.
Yeah. I mean, there's plenty of, uh,
instances of people where
they're obviously doing
something that's illegal and
getting away with it.
And somehow or another it becomes okay
because it's sanctioned or because it
falls into some sort of a,
an area where you're,
you're not allowed to look
into it and like, like this.
But the mega upload situation
is very fascinating to me
because I've always been,
I've always been of the opinion when it
comes to digital downloads and things
like movies and songs,
that it is a completely new area.
And all our laws,
like our piracy laws and property laws,
they,
they're very vague when it comes to
digital copies because digital copies,
like people,
you can call it piracy all day.
I had Paul Stanley from kiss on and
he kept insisting that it's stealing,
that it's stealing and my take on it
is it's only stealing if the person who
originally had it doesn't have it anymore.
Right.
If I take care of Muffin, you don't
have any muffin to eat. Exactly.
If I take your song, you still have
that song and so does everybody else.
Exactly. So it becomes an issue
of what is the song, what it,
what is it, where does
it go? It's not stolen.
Someone may have illegal illegally copied
it and put it up so that other people
can take it down and then it becomes
sort of almost like a matter of ethics.
Like if you appreciate the artist
and you want to support the artists,
there should be some way you can do that.
And I also have always said that if
someone can't afford to buy your songs,
like if they're a fan of your band,
but they have no money but they can,
they can download your, your music and
then one day pay to see you in concert.
Like you gained a fan,
right?
Or you that fan stayed
supporting you with? They did,
but they didn't have money to
buy your shit in the first place.
They would not have purchased it.
But now they have it and they
get to enjoy it and they're,
it's one more person to tell other.
And
I think statistics have shown that like
artists are making the majority of their
money now, like music artists through
live performances because this,
well, let, let's look at historically
what happened with music piracy.
Music piracy at a time when music was
incredibly expensive and inconvenient to
get was thriving.
And what stopped the vast majority
of music piracy was not crackdowns.
It wasn't lawsuits.
It was the availability of things like
apple iTunes that made music easy and
convenient and accessible to people.
And then the range of music that people
started consuming expanded massively.
So from an artistic perspective,
music is now thriving from a
money perspective. However,
a lot of that profit is
being concentrated in apple.
Here's the thing though, and I hate
to drag us back and you know this my,
my thing I'll,
I'll find a way to introduce but coin to
tie everything in and the way everyone
around me.
But one of the things I think that is
magical about bitcoin is because it allows
micro payments.
You can pay five pennies and you can
pay five pennies in such a way that the
person receiving the five
pennies still gets five pennies.
It doesn't get chewed up in fees and
transaction costs and things like that.
And you can do that instantaneously.
It offers on the Internet a completely
new business model for content and
artistic creation.
So this means that artists can now
sell a listen of a song rather than,
you know, the eternal perpetual
rights of reproduction of a song,
which is very expensive,
a single listen for a penny for a 10th
of a penny and actually do that without
most of that money going to apple or
visa or some of the intermediaries,
but go directly to the artist.
We're already seeing that artists are
beginning to use bitcoin to make a direct
connection between themselves and the
consumer gets most of the money come to
them instead of the intermediaries.
And it creates a new funding
model for content creators.
And this also applies to news and media
and bloggers and people who write and
make music and make youtube
videos for a living.
So until now it was really difficult
to earn money on the Internet.
And the reason for that is because you
are delivering a very small amount of
value to each one of your consumers,
but there was no payment mechanism by
which they could pay you for a very small
amount of money. They can only pay
you for $5 or more. And there's very,
it's very hard to bundle.
So as a result,
you end up doing two things.
You either sell the consumer themselves
by taking all their private information
and turning them into a profile and
selling the crap out of that to marketing
companies.
Or You cram advertising down
their eyeballs until they
hate what they're seeing.
And now we have a third
way, which is they actually pay
for the content they consume.
And that's revolutionary.
I mean it really is.
You could do some amazing things
with music and publishing.
It's incredibly difficult to get people
to pay for anything online though.
I mean that's always been the rub. The
rub is that the Internet is so available.
There's so much. Yeah, there's the,
it's essentially just this open ocean
of content that anybody coming along
saying, I want you to pay to read
my blog. Fuck off. You know, I've,
I've seen that before. I've
seen people say, you know, the,
you have to pay to read their blog and
when he got to be out of your fucking
mind,
no one's going to pay to read your blog.
People have a actually sent me links to
websites that have paid subscription,
like a link. Like on Twitter. It's
like really like kind of a scam.
Like they're sending me a link so that
hoping I retweet it and I'll click the
link and then they'll say to read more,
you know, subscribe. I'm like, fuck you.
Well,
how much does it cost to subscribe though?
Like five bucks or something like
that or something along those lines.
What if it was a penny Isaac,
he wanted to hear most. Okay.
If it's music you want to hear,
yes.
If it's a movie you want to
watch a documentary and watch,
but for a lot of things it's just people
are going to find if you find something
similar that's free, you're just
going to go towards that and if so,
if there's something like like reading
something like reading someone's blog,
that's a perfect example.
Most blogs are free.
The vast majority of blogs are free.
That's how people read them in the first
place because it doesn't cost me any
step that you take even a one click
Amazon step where it's so simple.
Amazon one click is just the most simple
thing of all time. I love it. I like it.
Bang, you hit that button.
It's on its way to you.
They already have your address in there.
It's just super easy to get even that,
like people like,
why do I have to pay for this when
I can just go to his blog and,
and, and read it for free or her blog
and read it for free. Why would I,
why would I give you money for
something that is available for free?
So when you get something like,
like a blog or a newspaper
online or a website, it's,
it's kind of already been clearly
established that that's a free service.
I think to a certain extent it has been.
The reason is that previously you were
representing the cost of production and
then with the Internet, the cost
of production fell to zero, right?
The value of what you're
delivering is a bit more than zero,
but it's not high enough to
charge a credit card or to
differentiate it from all
the other free things that are out there.
And there's no payment mechanisms that
fills that gap between zero and $5. Right?
So your cost dropped to zero,
your minimum charges $5 and
there's nothing in between. And,
and that means that a lot of things that
may be worth a dollar or 25 cents or 75
cents and people would actually pay
because you can only charge five or zero,
you end up going for zero.
And you say that because of bank fees.
That's why you can only charge
because yes, absolutely.
Because credit card,
minimum transactions online cannot go
below five and the inconvenience and the
information, the identity information
you provide and all of that.
So we haven't explored
that range of zero to $5.
And so if I could say for example,
right now the New York Times wants me to
pay 10 bucks a month to read more than
10 articles. But then if I want
to read the Washington Post,
I have to pay another 10 bucks a month
to read more than 10 of their articles.
And The Los Angeles Times has
experimented with something the same.
What if I could put down $2 a month
and read 25 articles from all of the
newspapers that I want to and just
put that into my browser and say,
I went to to allocate $2 a
month to newspaper articles.
I'm going to give them a
penny or half a penny each.
I'm going to read 25 50 a hundred
articles from all of the newspapers.
Now they're generating an actual revenue
stream and it may seem tiny when I'm
paying just a, you know, a
fraction of a penny per article.
You multiply that by a million consumers
and you got some real money coming in
more than they're making
with these pay walls,
so you start exploring that range
between zero and five four zero and $10 I
would pay for quality news
content without Todd futzing.
We know people will pay for things that
are free FBN proofs that apple iTunes
proves that when I can
go out and torn to song,
but it's more convenient for me to pay
a dollar 99 and just buy it to high
quality.
If you deliver high quality content and
you lower the barrier for paying enough
people will pay for high quality content.
And what we,
we can do with bitcoin is lower that
barrier enough that a whole range of
content that you could never charge for
before that was forced to free because
there's no intermediate step can now
make the artist and the creator income
directly without intermediaries,
without them taking a giant cut.
I think that's pretty exciting.
It is exciting.
Is there a way,
I was thinking this like you
remember the old days of dos and the,
the early versions of windows like with
the command line prompt and you know,
people who knew how to use and people did
and it was very prohibitive for people
who are uneducated and code.
Um,
and then came along the
modern graphic user interface.
And essentially what you're doing is
you're hiding all of that secret shit
behind it and you're creating
something that's much more simplistic.
Is there a way to do that with Bitcoin
to take away all these weird fucking
numbers and Zeros and ones and point
this point that and break it down to
something or would it have to be
stabilized first where the the actual,
the,
the price of Bitcoin or the value of
bitcoin would be stabilized to the point
where something like
that would be applicable?
I think you,
you nailed it.
We are in the dos days of digital money
and a lot of things need to change.
So what you have here, three things
that are happening simultaneously.
One is the evolution of the user
interface and user experience.
The other one is user adoption.
How many people are using it and how
many new people are using it every day.
And the third one is the price volatility
and those three are tied together.
You can't really get one before the other.
You can't really design beautiful user
interfaces if you have no users and no
value in the money,
you can't get users if you have no
beautiful interfaces and the money's too
volatile and the money won't become more
stable until you have more users using
easier interfaces.
So all three of these move together and
all you need to get to that is time.
So over time, if you look at
bitcoin today versus Bitcoin,
five years ago we had enormous progress
on the user end faces enormous progress
on the adoption and enormous
progress on the stability. And if,
and if you send say,
well it's a five year old now,
what will bitcoin look
like five years from now?
I think you're going to see bitcoin
addresses are going to disappear.
Just like Ip addresses.
We don't see them on the Internet anymore.
The user interfaces of Qr codes and
barcodes are going to disappear.
We're already seeing protocols that allow
you to do tap to pay and swipe to pay
like apple pay with bitcoin quite easily.
And that certainly
happened. Yes, absolutely.
You can do NFC as it's called near
field communications, like apple pay,
you can do tap to pay with Bitcoin,
but here's what you can't do with apple.
The account with Bitcoin, I can do
top to pay between two phones. Ah.
Like I could say t pay you with
bitcoin and with two phones.
Now do I need to do without
you being a merchant, right.
Cheetah cell service to do that
or can the phones communicator,
they can communicate
with each other offline.
So you can be on the fucking North Pole,
right,
with no self service and you could
swap big corn right back and forth.
You Playing Ping Pong?
Yes,
and all I'm doing is the same thing
I'm doing by scanning a barcode on it.
I'm using the NFC protocol
to do it. So, so you can,
you can see how this technology is going
to get smoother and easier to use as we
have more adoption and at the same time
the price stabilized it and all three of
those metrics if you like,
we'll move in parallel and
they'll gradually gets easier.
I remember a time of the
Internet with Ip addresses.
I remember a time with
Dawson Unix command line.
I remember a time when sending an email
if you need it to have those skills and
you know, you just watch that
progression of the technology.
The most important thing is not
only will these things happen,
but the companies that build these things
are building billion dollar industries.
So the company that figured out how to
find things on the internet became Google.
Some company's going to figure out
how to make bitcoin easier to use for
addresses.
Some company's going to find out how to
make bitcoin easier to use for retail,
for music payments, for social media, uh,
for international remittances.
And each one of those companies is
going to build $1 billion industry.
Yet it seems like that is really the
next step. Figuring out a way to do it.
Do you remember the IRC chat
clients? You know, like,
that's like Uber Geek Shit Man. You know,
I used to use those when I was in the,
my quick playing days.
We'd all meet on IRC channels and we
all compete completely dorks. Yeah,
that little thing that
would do that rolling sound.
I mean there's things like that where
only the Uber geeks adopt them and they
just stay that way. Like IRC chat clients
still to this day, you bring up Iris,
there's people that are on IRC right now.
The entire bitcoin development happens
in collaboration over IRC and those are
recent for that because it's
global, it's open, it's transparent,
it's free and it's scalable and so no one
has built a better chat, which it yet.
Yeah, so my, my, yeah, there really
hasn't been, I mean a Google hangout,
those things did,
I mean they were trying to come up with
something along those lines. Right.
But it didn't really take off.
Is that still around that
Google plus and sort of kind of,
I mean it, it, it is, but I don't think,
I don't know anyone that really uses it.
It's hiding behind all the other Google
products because it's now used as the
main account and profile page. I have a
friend who's fucking, she works at Google,
she's an exec,
Google and you bring it up and she's a,
she'll millions of people use Google
hang out and millions of people are on
Google pross right now just cause they
force you to sign up every time you go to
youtube and shit like that.
Exactly.
In that way it's very similar to Sirius
satellite radio subscription numbers.
Cause you know how when you
buy a new car it comes with a,
a car radio that has serious on it
and you're subscribed for 90 days.
Like we added 50,000 new subscribers.
Right.
But how many of them were giving
you any fucking money at all?
Like how many of them are just getting
their subscription as a 90 day free trial
from, you know, buying
a Chevy or whatever.
It's even worse than that because
then they say we've got millions of
subscribers on Google plus we'll,
you're a billion user company.
So that means only one in a
thousand is using it. Yeah.
I don't even think it's that many.
I mean,
I go on Google plus every now
and then and it's like a fucking,
it's like one of those buildings that
they build in China where no one actually
moves into them.
You ever see those?
A lot of the empty mega cities that ghost
towns. That's what Google plus is like.
I mean,
maybe I'm wrong,
maybe I'm just tapping into the wrong
Google plus communities and I'm just
missing a whole vein of interaction
that's an incredibly enriching and amazing
and magical. But I'm
not seeing it now. No.
But everyone's trying to come
up with something like the IRC,
like something that some or any
other social media platform. Any,
any other place where people can
communicate and make easy and make it less
forbidding. And I think there's
something about IRC they'll like,
to some people it's like,
it's just too fucking crazy,
the new, uh, where they take like,
at least with apple and Mac or they
now have like chat on your phone. Like,
now if you get a phone call,
it will ring on your computer and I will
ring on your phone and you can always
rings on your,
yeah,
you can set it up now with the Yosemite
or whatever the new operating system is.
That's annoying. It is. It isn't mine.
But it's great when your phone's dead
and you just want to like answer a phone
call real quick on, you know,
you could like, Hey, what's up?
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
So if your phone is dead, your,
your computer will ring.
Peter will ring or your iPad will ring
and you could set it up for anything.
But the thing I use the most is
the chat now is on all of them.
So you can, uh, I can
like chat on my computer,
like IRC and be like sending you
files and videos and stuff like that.
It as a text message.
Yeah.
And you'll get as a text message and
then I'll just go onto my bad thing also
with that is, uh, you know,
you go to work and then you leave your
iPad open and your girlfriend can see
every single thing you
who is your girlfriend?
What about anybody or your mom,
your mom sr six Sr Dick
Pics. Yeah, exactly. Now,
if that's the case,
like can you use your computer to make
phone calls if there's an internet
connection, but there's no,
there's no cellular connection.
Slowly and certain
t-mobile does where you can be on your
phone at your house on Wifi and then
leave your house and it will
just jump to sell your service.
So you're not using your minutes when
you're at your house, but then, uh,
it goes right to your self service
right when you leave your house.
So it's handing off from
Wifi to LTE or whatever you,
right.
That's amazing that they can do that.
Because you remember how it used to
drop off when you switch tower? Yeah.
So does that on, on, on
some networks really? Yeah.
So like as you're driving on the highway,
it's still disconnects when you and you
have signals just switching from tower
to tower. Yeah, a handoff. Uh,
technology is still pretty
shitty and a lot of cities,
that's crazy that they can use that
technology to go from your cellular
connection to your Internet
connection's seamlessly,
but they can't figure that out yet.
All right.
Google voice does that for a number of
customers and that it's a product they've
never really advertised. I've been a
Google voice customer now for six years.
It's a free service.
I have a phone number that's Google
rings my cell phone and brings my desktop
rings every device on Nare. I can forward
it to all kinds of interesting things.
Here's what happened there.
You took a telephone call,
which used to be a network and you turned
it into a content types that rides on
top of the intranet. So now it
can ride on any network, right?
So you separate the
medium from the message,
you separate the content type from the
thing that's running on top of it and now
you can take that same thing,
a telephone call and do it
independent of telephone networks.
It can be on the landline,
cellular Wifi or any Internet
connection anywhere you have TCP IP.
And the argument I'd be making about
bitcoin recently has been this the w we're
just doing that for money for
the first time. So up to now,
money has had networks and the type of
money you use and how you use it and what
it can do depends on the network.
So if you want to do consumer to business,
you can use visa,
mastercard or American Express is going
to come with a certain specific fee.
It's going to work only in some countries.
You can only move a
certain amount of money.
If you want to move money between banks,
you're going to use swift,
the worldwide interbank fun transfer.
If you want to move money between
checking accounts, you can use a ACH,
the clearinghouse here in the u s so
that's how you move money between checking
accounts.
If you want to move money
between one of these things,
then it gets complicated.
So like if you want to move
using a visa card to a consumer,
you can't really do it. You'll have to
use a check and things get really hairy.
So you have these islands,
uh,
networks that can support small
payments only or large payments only.
They can do fast money or slow money
that can do a government money,
business money or consumer
money and none of them mix.
So you can't switch between them.
Well bitcoin does small and large,
fast and slow government and consumer.
And it spans all of these networks.
Exactly like the Internet took
photography and moved it across all of the
networks, took video and now there's no
difference between cinema, TV, you know,
all of these different formats and took
telephone calls and move them outside of
their own network.
Now we're doing that to money as a
pretty weird thing because when you turn
money into a form of communication,
it on shackles it from all of these
restrictions you can now do any amount.
It's most country you can send money to
a person and not have any intermediary.
You not have any third party.
That third party has got to
get pretty fucking nervous.
And what has been the reaction as far
as like banks or propaganda or any
negative and negative reaction from
the powers of be about this possible
technology?
Um, for the most part it kind of depends
on what kind of bank we're talking about
because there are
different types of banks.
Like there are banks that are
primarily focused on consumer services,
checking savings, payment systems. Um,
then there are banks that are mostly
about playing the market, right?
Some of the big six banks,
they,
they've actually pulled out of doing
consumer checking a city for example,
recently pulled out of
12 different countries.
No longer do consumer banking at
all. Uh, it's too complicated,
has too many people involved who
cause problems. Whereas if you do,
what is it? Well, no,
I mean it's not a very profitable
business because you have to deal with
customers and they're fickle. But
instead, if you're only customers,
the Federal Reserve and
they give you free money,
why on earth would you do consumer check?
Right? It's not profitable. So, um,
some banks will look at bitcoin
and either think it's a threat,
but most likely at this point
still think it's a joke.
Like they can't possibly imagine any way
that this little experiment could ever
threaten serious banking.
Right?
So now they're looking at like little
kids trading marbles or something, right?
It's what I called the,
um,
the idea that a lemonade stand
is going to threaten Walmart.
That's what it appears to be to them.
Then you've got banks that
deal with consumer checking.
I've talked to a lot of banks that
look at this and say, for example,
I talked to a bank in Brazil and they
have about 80 million people who have very
little access to banking.
And the reason they have very little
access to banking is because the nearest
bank branch to their location is a
hundred miles up river on a canoe,
right? In the Amazon Basin,
it's opposite of bitcoin. It's,
it's one of the most sparsely
populated countries in the world.
So Brazil is an enormous country.
It's a third of the continent
of South America. And,
and some of the places are really,
really furry remote.
But even though the bank branch is
a hundred miles downriver by canoe,
does a cell phone tower in
the business and the Bush,
there's a cell phone tower in
the middle of nowhere. Why?
Because you can air lift it in,
you can plant it,
you can put a microwave link that goes
2030 a hundred miles and you can power it
with solar. So they've actually planted
cell phone towers. Now if you could.
So they look at bitcoin and they think,
you know what?
The villages have a cell phone tower
and they already have a Nokia 1000 that
does text messaging. Can I use bitcoin
to turn that into a bank terminal?
Now I can get 80 million new customers
and give them banking that they've never
had before. So some banks
are thinking that way, right?
Banks in South Africa and
Brazil, in India, in China,
in Indonesia,
in places where you have very
sparse remote populations.
And then there's other banks
here in the u s the smaller ones,
they can't compete on marketing.
They can compete on market size and
economies of scale and they can compete on
buying politicians faster
than the big banks.
So they need a secret weapon and they
look a bit coin and they think, well,
you know what? This is a settlement
and clearing house network.
And there's these companies
that do settlements,
the charge of 3% could we
take them out of business?
Could we disinter mediate them?
So they look, there's all of these
companies that are private but effectively
have monopoly positions that do all
of the clearing. The only banks know about
them. The depository trust corporation,
Clearinghouse Corporation, which
basically clears all equity settlement.
So when you buy stocks
on the stock market,
you buy the stock in three days later,
that goes through a batch
process that clears that stock,
exchanges the money and gives
you ownership. That's run
by a company called DTCC.
That company charges a lot of money
to do something very slowly and
inefficiently. And the banks
look at that and say, Hey,
could we use big point to take DTCC
out of business to take swift out of
business to build our
own networks that are,
that don't have a middleman because to us,
the bank is a third party,
but to a bank, there's another third
party. Right. And they can take them out.
That's fascinating.
So in a sense,
what these banks can use in s and even
the people in in Brazil that are setting
up these towers can use bitcoin for is
it's almost like a ability to send an
exchange money without
using the money itself.
They do it through bitcoin and then that
money can be transferred back and forth
from bitcoin to money or to whatever
their local currency is. Or not.
Either that or use the
underlying technology.
For bitcoin to build their
own parallel networks.
So just like for example,
in the first few years,
the big phone companies with terrified
of the Internet and things like Skype
because it threatened that long distance
market. The smaller companies that were,
didn't really have a lot of
revenue from long distance,
saw this as an opportunity to link
together calling cards and long distance
offers and things like that and run
back bound backbones over TCP IP to cut
their costs.
So here they had a more
efficient transportation
network for transporting voice
data, so now they could
compete against at and t.
So even though the big companies
see may see it as a threat,
the smaller companies see it as a
weapon they can use in competition.
It's fascinating.
Then when you have companies that are
worried about their businesses becoming
obsolete,
when technology renders almost
anything that's not up to snuff,
obsolete. Do you remember when
they used to have calling cards?
They used to get a calling card,
used to have
punching the number when you would go
somewhere and you would use there the the
local payphone,
and that's how you used,
nobody has a fucking calling card anymore,
is
anybody,
what is it?
Even one 10th of 1% of the population
that uses one of those fucking thing.
The US, yes, but in the Philippines
and Indonesia and Africa,
there's a lot of calling cards because
the main phone companies still maintained
monopolies,
but gradually the Internet has
been breaking down those barriers.
And Brian's ring, even calling cards
obsolete. Here's the interesting thing.
The companies that are submerged in
their existing technology paradigm,
they're submerged in this
technology that's becoming obsolete.
They're blind to it.
They cannot possibly imagine a time
when this enormous edifice that they've
built,
we'll come collapsing.
Kodak could not imagine the fact that
film photography would become obsolete
because of phones,
because of phones.
And the funny thing is it wasn't a smart
move by Fujifilm or Nikon or one of
their existing competitors.
One day they were king of
the hill and I hear later,
a little company from Finland
they'd never heard of,
became the largest camera manufacturer
in the world's Nokia and started putting
out more cameras than any camera
manufacturer in the world in a year.
That was a transition in 1995 and
Kodak's suddenly got competition from a
completely unexpected thing. And what did
they do? They ridiculed it. They said,
well, that grainy, they're shaky.
You'll never get a real quality
camera photo out of that.
People will still love their
crisp, clear, 24 exposures of film.
There's artistic value to it's blah,
blah, blah. And three years later,
the facing bankruptcy. Now that's
incredible. After that happened,
they went bankrupt. They went by
some other, I mean three years,
three years after the ascendancy of
Nokia that they were facing bankruptcy.
And eventually,
despite all of their efforts to go digital
and all of that crashed and burned.
It's amazing. And, and this has
happened throughout history.
The companies that are best positioned,
like you would think the Kodak could do
digital photography better than anybody
else. I mean, they understood
photography. They had the brand,
they had the market recognition.
Photographers loved them.
So why couldn't they make
a play in this space?
And history shows us
that the companies can't,
they can't turn around fast enough.
They, they underestimate the risk.
They overestimate the value
of the old technology.
And we see this again and again.
Remember, you know, tower records.
MP3S are never going to replace vinyl
because vinyl has this depth and richness
of sound. And people will always go
for quality over this cheap, metallic,
crappy digital music.
We'll buy by tower records
and, and, and this happens, it
post a video blockbuster video.
And if you go further back,
you know,
it's like people will not drive these
internal combustion horseless carriages
because they're dangerous. They're
noisy, they're smelly, the roads,
there's no roads, there's no gasoline.
Only crazy people would use them.
Trust in the horse.
It's always worked for you.
It's worked for thousands of years.
And the interesting thing is even though
the companies that made horse buggies
had all of the manufacturing to make
buggies and could see a radically just
pivot slightly stick an
internal combustion engine,
they already had all of the
relationships with them.
We'll makers with the spring makers with,
they understood how to
build vehicle worthy row,
roadworthy vehicles.
All of them went out to business except
for one Studebaker was the only after
less than two decades,
Studebaker was the only us horse buggy
manufacturer that survive the transition
into the automobile.
Are there,
I wonder if it's possible at this point
in time for bank manufacturers if,
I mean, you know, people who are
creating banks, you know, people,
Citibank and Bank of America
to to look at all that. It's,
is it possible to look at all that,
that history and see that
you've got something coming up.
Just like the Nokia Camera,
you've got something coming up like it
might take a few years to, to settle in,
but once people realize that you can do
pretty much anything right now you can't.
But once you can start
buying cars and went homes,
vacations, paying for all these
things with Bitcoin, how much of it,
how much money are people
going to want to put in banks?
How much are they going to want to deal
with the idea of these third parties?
And if that starts to happen,
how about the fucking Federal Reserve?
That's where things get really squirrely.
Cause Ryan is that Weirdo
fucking institution,
that Jekyll Island fucking
strange institution that
we've been relying on for so
long.
Well, um, to your first
point is the people who are,
or who involved in the presence day model
of banking's a three to five business
days to clear your check, the
fees, the banking hours, the slow,
obsolete and inefficient.
They're never going to change that.
And the reason that they're, they're
going to take that all the way to Boston.
And the reason for that is because they
can't possibly see a world where the
alternative really does win.
And it won't happen gradually.
It won't be like, oh well, you know,
Bitcoin is getting closer or digital
cards to getting closer to taking our
business.
Maybe we should now start changing things.
It happens like with most technologies,
nothing happens for a while and the
interest builds up and then one day
something clicks,
something changes.
And the entire industry
flips. You know, for Kodak,
this happened in about a year and a half.
So the first camera phone came out and
you across the mega pixel barrier and
boom, the entire industry flipped and
nobody bought film anymore. And so,
and especially with banking,
the crazy thing is that there's 4 billion
people out there who have never had
banking. And that's great because they
don't ever have to experience that mass.
They can go directly to a digital currency
just like they never had landlines.
They went directly to cellular telephony.
And so you see this leapfrogging of
technology now as to the Federal Reserve.
And most people don't even know what,
this isn't how it works.
You know the Federal Reserve Bank,
it's the name is on the dollar bill.
So it's a government organization rights.
It's a government institution.
No it's not.
It's a private company run by the banks
that has the right to create money out
of nothing.
And then so vat to the u s government
in exchange for debt and if that doesn't
sound crazy to you,
I mean what does that,
that is insanity and that organization
has the ability to pre create an infinite
amount of money set the interest rates
between bank lending and is completely
independent of government control and
that was considered a good thing because
government manipulated money.
Now money manipulates government.
That's incredible, isn't
it? It's incredible.
They're allowed to use the word federal.
I'm going to,
I'm going to start calling
my comedy federal comedy.
It's a government approved comedy, but
it's not. It's federal comedy, right?
This is a,
this is a federal podcast like what the
fuck is federal is supposed to mean the
federal government. That's what
everybody automatically assumes,
right?
The,
the time in which the Federal Reserve
was created is a very strange time in the
history of this country.
All of this is an experiment that's less
than a hundred years old and I think in
retrospect will appear to most people
to be a failed experiments that was done
may no sense from the very beginning,
well to hustle. Let me, and
that's really what it is.
It's a money grab on a large scale and
incredibly large scale that includes the
politicians that were involved
and allowing it to form
the people that are alive,
that are allowing it to
continue the amount of money
that's being exchanged over
between these banks.
The amount of influence these banks have,
the decisions that have been made
directly because of the influence of these
banks that have not benefited the
American people in any way, shape or form.
All those things. When that's taken
into consideration in history,
we're going to look back and
go, well, these were mad times,
these were crazy people.
And, and the thing is there's
this illusion of stability.
There's the solution that
because the system is so big,
it can't possibly be fragile,
but the truth is exactly the opposite.
It has become incredibly fragile.
It is extremely overextended and
extremely fragile. And you see the,
the Federal Reserve at the moment has
been pumping money into the economy like
crazy for five years. And as they do
that, you get diminishing returns.
So every here they put the same
amount of money in and they,
they move the economy,
they move the stock market a bit less
and then they put more money in and it
moves a bit lesson until they're
putting money in just to keep it stable.
Now I've seen that pattern before.
I mean that looks like a cocaine habit
right
in the first year,
right?
The coke addict is snorting a lot of
free Federal Reserve money and the stock
market's getting really high end
deeds. Bye Bye here. Five it takes a,
it takes a big fat line of Federal
Reserve money just just to keep the stock
market from crashing in the morning.
And then one day,
which happens in mid October,
the Federal Reserve turned off
the tap a month ago.
Federal Reserve stopped giving
out free money to the banks.
We haven't seen the effect that
will have in the stock market,
but if you follow your
cocaine addict analysis, um,
right now that addict is Jonesing for
a hit and is really, really cranky.
So it means that things could happen.
Yeah,
there are about seven to eight months
away from suck and trucker dicks and
that's really what's going
on. I mean, they're about,
they're about that far away,
but the amount of power that the bank has,
that's the federal bank,
the World Bank,
the amount of power all of them have
is really incredible and it should have
never taken place.
I mean,
the power is always supposed
to been something that was you.
You're supposed to have the people
who choose a representative.
The representative looks after the
will of the people. The people talk,
they have discourse.
There's debates and discussions and we'd
take into account social welfare and
education and all these things that you
would like your money to be distributed
to.
And instead what you
have is the money itself.
Having this massive amount of power
and the people who print the money,
having this massive amount of power
and generating, printing the money,
but generating incredible sums of money
because the fact they print the money,
which is when you see these fuckers,
these Wall Street fuckers that are
living in these Hampton, these,
they have these houses in the
Hamptons that are, I mean they're not,
they don't even look real.
If you ever seen some of those guys that,
let me think of these. A thousand
fucking acres are hundreds of acres,
giant fucking palatial compounds and
you find a, what does this guy do? Oh,
he's just moving numbers or,
no,
you got to realize, show that
they're not rich by world standards.
They're not rich. The Pie, the
people who are really rich,
they own islands and countries and they
don't even mingle with these little
small time bankers. It
here's, here's the thing.
Sometime in the 20th century,
the,
this idea of governments being able to
print unlimited money was considered the
scientific approach to money.
That if somehow we could control things
a bit better in terms of tweaking
interest rates and pouncing,
unemployment and inflation,
we could use the scientific method in
terms of monetary policy because gold was
too inefficient and you had to ship it
across the waters and big barges and
things like that. Yeah. If we could
use a scientific method for economics,
we would see prosperity and we would see
growth and things like that. Instead,
what happens, governments had the
ability to print on limited money.
So now they could go to
war without raising taxes.
And what they did is they went to war
again and again and again and again and
again.
And a lot of the money in the 20th
century was pumped directly into war,
a war on scale with it.
Never happened before.
And spending four on a scale
that had never happened before.
And now you end up with economies
like the US. The U S is addicted tour.
We've been at war continuously since 1930,
38,
uh, pretty much continuously in
dozens and dozens of countries.
And it is the machine that creates
stimulus. So anytime the economy starts,
you know, we can in a bit,
we start another war and,
and we get another enormous
amount of stimulus money. In fact,
we saw recently the third quarter and
fourth quarter results for GDP are
presumably a bit better in the u s and
that happened to coincide with a massive
influx of money to fight isis.
You know,
the latest bogey men,
by the way,
Isis is the same organization we
funded against acid just a year ago.
So ally enemy,
very quick transition.
And now all of this money
going into fighting a new
enemy on a new battle front.
But none of that money is going to
improve schools, roads, healthcare,
or are the things in this country,
all of the government gets to print money.
They use it for war every
time throughout history.
And so the fact that governments were
freed from sound monetary policy and we're
given the ability to print infant as
money has ended up being a scourge on
humanity.
It's ended up creating whore just for
profit because you don't need to tax
people to go to war and now you
don't need to conscript people.
You can make it just the only employment
opportunity that exists in some states
and Bingo,
you've got remote controlled,
highly profitable war that doesn't affect
the vast majority of the population
and that has become the new
form of economic activity.
That's one of the reasons why I think
that the same reason why states can't be
trusted with religion,
then you need separation of church and
state because when they take religion,
they use it as a form of power to beat
down people for the very same reason.
You need separation of state and money.
When states and money became one,
only bad things have happened and we
need to go back to some of the earlier
times.
In fact that that's a weird thing about
bitcoin is this tremendously futuristic
technology one that neither
star trek or star wars, no,
the Jetsons predicted like all of
these truly disruptive technologies.
It wasn't even imagined in Scifi,
but its origins and its basis is actually
pretty conservative and traditional.
It's the idea of money by the people
and for the people without it being
nationalized.
State money.
Ben Franklin as one of
the founding partners, a,
our founding fathers
was a printer, right? His main
business outside of, you know,
being a rough solutionary and one
of the founding fathers was he,
he ran a print shop,
he printed stuff.
He run a whole empire of print shops
all across the, the United States.
And one of the things he printed was money
because at the time money was made by
banks and by states. So it wasn't
made by the federal government.
The federal government
didn't have one money, right?
Every state had its own and
Virginia money that was, you know,
you have some money. That was main
money. That was Rhode Island money,
those New York money. Uh, and there
was also corporate money being printed,
printed by companies.
And that was one of the main reasons
that the British crown was pissed off was
because all of these little free state
money printing operations where we're
sucking taxes out of,
out of her queens money.
Big Part of why the war started.
Right.
And Ben Franklin was was the
original peer to peer money printer.
Now bitcoin is doing,
that's again only in a digital form and
governments tell us that can't possibly
work. What I would say the
evidence is the opposite. In fact,
that worked pretty well for many,
many centuries and this current model
is less than a hundred years old and has
resulted in perpetual war
and terrible inflation,
unemployment and depression. That
model can't work well. That model,
not only can it not work,
the people that are a part of that
model actively campaign against it,
I mean everybody that runs for president
talks about how they want to stop war.
We're going to pull out of Afghanistan,
we're going to close down Guantanamo Bay,
we're going to do this and do that
and we're going to bring back peace.
But meanwhile, the very machine that
puts them in place is a machine that's,
that relies on more and needs war and
it's one of those things where you have a
path that is so deeply carved into the
ground that it's almost impossible if you
traveling next to it, not the slide
into it. It becomes just this, this,
there's money, it gets generated.
This is a way to get that money.
This is a way to figuring out a way
to put it all together. And it just,
it's a pattern.
It's a pattern that's repeated itself
over and over and over again to the point
where something disruptive has to be
introduced into the system. Excuse me,
in order to stop that pattern
and create something new.
And we begin to see that
because in the past, um,
even the very communications of political
campaigns and elections were channeled
through a few very narrow in our
channels like TV, right? And radio.
And those gave the gatekeepers hell of
a lot of power because if they didn't
like political candidate,
they could just silence them.
What the Internet did,
not successfully yet,
but what it started doing is changing
that equation and allowing candidates who
otherwise wouldn't have a voice
to have a voice. You know.
So for example, uh, the,
the RNC broke their own rules at the
convention in order to keep Ron Paul from
speaking back in 2008.
Right?
But they couldn't stop him from speaking.
And raising a lot of advocates
and followers on the Internet.
They could keep him off TV,
they could keep him out of the debates,
they could keep him out of the
convention by breaking their own rules,
but they couldn't keep
him off the Internet.
And so the Internet allowed candidates
communicate directly with our
constituents.
Well now with Internet money you have
the ability to those constituents to fund
the campaigns directly and I guarantee
you it's going to be a tiny, tiny,
tiny amount.
At first,
just like initially internet
communications were negligible,
trivial compared to TV spend.
Right.
And then a couple of candidates
started changing that.
Howard Dean started running an Internet
based campaign from Paul Run an Internet
based campaign and even Obama himself
eventually ended up using the Internet to,
to run his own campaign.
And your,
and suddenly the Internet had influence
in communications. They're going to see,
start seeing some politicians taking
bitcoin and other digital currencies for
the campaign finance. And at first
we're going to laugh at it, right?
It's going to be ridiculous.
It's going to be like a lemonade stand
taken on Walmart and then give it a
decade and you could see a significant
shift in the source of money for campaign
contributions. I think that's, you know,
kind of interesting what could happen
there if you shift both the power of
communication and the power of
fundraising for elections to the people.
Well,
I am,
whenever you have new
variables that people started
adopting and they get thrown
into the system and become a part of
the system and then become commonplace,
it shakes things up. I mean, just
like the camera's that Nokia created,
just like the Internet itself,
essentially 1990 what fourish
people started adopting it.
Let me, when was like, what was that?
Back then it was compuserve and AOL,
right?
Just a few companies
and Netscape fall.
It's by Yahoo and Altavista,
which started creating
things that were interesting
and 20 that's 20 years.
It's a blink of blink in time in the
world has changed so incredibly much so
much different than 1994 when it
comes to access to information. It's,
it's impossible for
someone who is grown up.
You talked to a 20 year old kid today and
explain to them what it was like to be
a 20 year old kid in 1985
and they'll laugh at you.
They can't see the world. How
could they, how could they write?
When I tried to explain what it
was like for me to be 20 I'm like,
I was like a monkey.
I was like some dummy
with books like that was,
that was where you got your information
from books and from like things that you
would see on television that were on
television. Like you couldn't stop them,
you couldn't rewind them, you
couldn't DVR them. Like the idea,
the access to information did.
The idea of information has shifted
so radically to Google on your phone.
I mean that is,
that's so Jetsons.
It's so beyond anything
anybody comprehended
but Jetsons never imagined that.
That's the interesting thing about it
is that if you look at some of these
disruptive technologies,
things like the Jetsons and star Trek
and star wars and things like that,
they anticipate the current technology
and they just extrapolates linearly and
if, if the person is really a
visionary who comes up with it,
sometimes they take a slight twist
and amplify one side of it and create
something exciting and then
they miss the simple things.
They miss the really obvious things. Like
they figured out mobile communicators,
but they didn't figure
out email or social media.
I was talking to someone who is saying
they wrote a book on the Jetsons,
Jeffrey Tucker from Liberty Dot. Me.
He was, he was saying the, you know,
one of the fascinating thing about the
Jetsons is that they would have flying
cars and pneumatic choose and
robots and all of these things,
but when the kid took a note from
school back to his parents who would be
written on paper,
yeah,
they couldn't imagine email. Where is,
it seems obvious to us now. It was,
it wasn't simply a continuation
of the past. It didn't have,
it was completely new. And all of
the really interesting technologies,
the ones that don't just take what you
have now and extrapolate that they break
that mold completely and you
see like look at Star Trek,
right? They just gave up on
money. They just gave up.
They just don't talk about it at all.
There is no money in star trek. So true.
They just fighting so much. What are the
Clinton's are looking for? Like crystals,
right? Well, I mean there's energy there.
There's all kinds of things, but you know,
they kind of gloss over money entirely
and that's because money's a different
difficult technology to
imagine where it's going. And,
and the same thing in a lot of Saifai,
you know,
you don't see social media,
you don't see email and you certainly
don't see digital money as much.
Or if people see digital money,
it's effectively apple pay, right?
You have a thing and you'd go bloop
and it pays in galactic credits.
But that's not very imaginative. That's
just our current money on a phone, right?
Yeah, they're just using
placeholders. Right.
But the truly interesting technologies
start happening when you break that mold
and you create forms of money
that didn't exist before and,
and ways to use money
that didn't exist before.
So the ability,
for example,
one of the really revolutionary
things about bitcoin that I,
I find fascinating is the ability
for machines to own money.
So up to now only people can own
money or through legal fiction,
it's like corporations,
groups of people can own money,
but machines cannot own, operate and
exchange money on their own. Software
systems cannot own money on their own.
They have to have a human
paying for things, right?
So think about this concept which has
been discussed a lot in the bitcoin
community called a distributed
autonomous corporation or decentralized
autonomous corporation or
organization, Dao Dac. Um,
imagine a software agent that is able
to maintain a bitcoin balance and uses
that to pay for its own hosting on say,
a web service. So you, so it
rents its own computer power.
So you essentially empower the, the
software company, you, your servers,
you write software,
right?
So that it can manipulate
a bitcoin account and then
use that bitcoin account to
buy hosting to copy copies
of itself onto that hosting.
Isn't that one then [inaudible] itself
is an autopay similar. Hang on a second.
Now imagine taking that a step further.
Now imagine if that software system
could create two varieties of itself,
like by making a small change
and one virus of the software,
it gets hosted here in one fair gets
hosted there and say it does an activity
like it,
it creates content on blogs by
aggregating news and sells advertising for
Bitcoin. And if this one's successful,
it buys more hosting for itself.
And if this one isn't successful,
it shrinks the amount of hosting.
So now you've got almost a fitness
function, evolutionary effect going on.
So now the most successful versions of
the software grow in size and fund more
of themselves now could go
out on craigslist and hire
some software developers
to make it software better.
You've essentially got an autonomous agent
that's acting with money to propagate
its own existence. That's
never happened before. And,
and I don't know what you could do with
that. Uh, probably some very weird,
some very bad,
some very good things all mixed together,
but it opens a door to something that is
completely crazy Saifai level and when
you take that and you connect it to,
I'm sure you've been paying attention to
the Ilan Musk statements that he's made
recently about artificial
technology that it's a,
you're summoning the demon and he believes
that within five years he ordinarily,
I would read things like that and goes
some crazy futurist guys written really
not, doesn't have his finger on the
pulse of the actual technology itself,
but when you got a guy like Elon Musk
who obviously is a fucking super genius
and he starts saying things like that
you might take into consideration, hey,
maybe this guy is thinking
about some possibilities,
some variables than other people are
just trying to ignore because we ignore a
lot of variables automatically. We ignore
the variable that we're going to die.
We like to ignore that one. We sort of
know it exists, but we try to put it away.
We ignore the variable that the earth
itself doesn't have a very long life.
I mean in terms of cosmic viability,
it's like we gotta like
go another billion years.
We can't support life anymore because
the sun's going to be too hot.
It'll fucking eventually supernova
the whole year. You mean there's,
there's only certain amount of time
for everything right now when you're
creating intelligent life forms and you
are in creating essentially some sort of
autonomous physical thing that is
going to be able to think for itself,
you're going to have some sort of
thing that can mimic thinking or or,
or actually has the ability to think,
propagate ideas,
push forth its own agenda and do that on
its own and has bitcoin as money it can
think and it has a bank account and it
could think how to generate income and it
could think of what it could do with
that income to ensure that it keeps its
existence.
Well,
there are ways you can think about
it and you know, for the time being,
the amount of action such an entity
could take in the physical world is very
limited. It needs people
to act as it's Asian. So,
so some of the applications, you can put
it to a really interesting, for example,
you can create a distributed charity
organization that has charitable members
and built an endowment fund.
And then can you use a vote among its
members to execute charitable action.
So you can essentially have a corporation
that is programmable where it doesn't
depend on what a board of directors does,
but instead it has a code basis and all
of the shareholders get to vote directly
on what that does. And all
of the members say, oh,
there was an earthquake in
this place in the world.
75% of the members voted to send
part of the endowment for charitable
contributions.
And now you have a charitable organization
that acts directly in the interest of
its members and contributors
without any influenced by a board.
That's kind of an interesting
concept. You can do some very, um,
you can use transparency
and accountability and
governance in interesting ways.
If you do that.
There's a whole section of development
here called Bitcoin two dot.
O and the two dot Oh version of bitcoin.
And I hate the term two. Dot. Oh.
Because you know, it's so overused.
Web Two. Dot. O was social
media. It was kind of a, uh,
a deviation from the standard pattern
of making publications centric sites to
making people centric sites.
So bitcoin to Dodo is moving from
currency centric applications to contract
centric applications where instead
of running a currency on the network,
what you're running as a contract is
basically a piece of code that can execute
contracts such as an agreement between
two people to buy and sell a house.
And you can now take that and run
that as a contract on the network.
And it can handle not just the payment
but also the registration of title,
the escrow,
things like you can have a contract.
Here's one other application
as a company called Air Lock,
which makes a digital
lock for airbnb locations,
brand new company based on the
Bitcoin to doto technology.
And the idea here is that you put a
digital lock on the door and when you sign
the contract to rent an
airbnb location or something,
the tax like Airbnb,
you send a payment of bitcoin and the
payment itself authorizes the pair to
unlock the door.
So the same bitcoin keys you use to make
the payment now authorize you to open
the door to that property so you can
go and enjoy your stay for as long as
you've paid.
So you've combined a smart currency with
a smart contract and a smart assets,
which is the door lock.
So now you can open anything.
Another company has built a fluid
dispenser, so it's a fluid dispense,
a where for a fixed price you can buy
certain number of gallons of something and
then dispense them simply by sending
a bitcoin payments to that pump.
Essentially it can imagine this
for a gas pump, a water pump,
hydrogen pump, you know, whatever you
want. And the thing that you can pump oil,
high fructose corn syrup,
coffee whenever,
and it's regulated by the amount
of Bitcoin that you've spent. Yeah.
So there's a ratio of
milliliters, leaders, gallons,
fluid ounces or whatever
you want the unit to be,
and a price for that particular
substance in that particular volume.
And you pay for the volume and you,
you then put a cop or car or
buckets underneath and dispense.
Have any gas stations adopted bitcoin
yet? No. That would be fascinating.
But you can see where the
possibilities go. Oh, finally,
there's,
there's this concept of smart property,
which I think we touched on it
before now. Uh, in June of this gear,
I sold my car for Bitcoin.
And that in itself was a very
instructive, um, transaction.
Because if you want to sell a car,
you have a couple of really big
risk areas. If you're the buyer,
you're going to a transaction with a
whole bundle of cash with you, right?
And that means you can get robbed.
And so it's pretty dangerous
when you're buying a car.
You don't just randomly pick up an ad,
a Goto,
a remote parking lot with
a bundle of cash. That's,
that's how people get killed,
right? If you're a seller, if you don't,
if you receive cash, you've got
to make sure it's not counterfeit.
And most people can't tell the difference.
So there's a big risk that you're
gonna receive a bunch of money,
but that money isn't going to be real.
You give your car away,
you have fake money,
you're in trouble now. Um,
or if instead of taking cash, you want
to take a check, that check could bounce.
If it's a bank draft, it could be forged.
If it's a money order, it could be faked.
So what you now need to do is arrange
to meet the car buyer near bank branch.
Go in with the car buyer,
have them deposit the check or bank draft,
have the bank validated,
have the bank confirmed the amount.
Now you can only do this between
nine and four 13 the afternoon,
Monday to Friday,
I sold my car to 11:00 PM on a Wednesday
night and I sold it to someone who
wasn't in the same state as I was buying
the car on behalf on behalf of his
brother, who was a student in
the state where I was California.
I meet the brother,
they do a test ride. Um,
they call up their brother and say,
yeah, I really want to buy this.
Can you send the bitcoin?
I send them the bitcoin address.
We're in a parking lot in
the middle of the night.
They're not worried I'm going to rob them
cause they don't have any cash on them.
I'm not worried they're going to cheat
me because I'm going to see a bitcoin
payment. So easy peasy,
really late at night.
The brother does the transfer of
bitcoin. I told him, okay, wait here,
I'm going to go grab a sandwich.
I'm going to be back in about 45 minutes.
Once the bitcoin transaction is confirmed,
fully and settled can be reversed.
Nothing. I'll be back 45 minutes
later, sandwich done back.
I give them title and key and they
drive away. Transaction was safe.
It had happened outside of banking hours.
Now here's the twist.
Bitcoin to Dodo.
You know a lot of cars today
have digital ignition systems,
electronic ignition systems,
so your key isn't just a metal key.
It's also a radio transmitter that has
a special chip inside it to identify
itself to your car. So if you just
break the lock with a screwdriver,
you're not going to start the car because
the electronic ignition system is not
going to recognize your key and
it's going to say no, sorry. Right?
So the key itself is a digital key.
Imagine if you could do the following.
If I make a transaction
that transfers money,
bitcoin to the owner of the car and the
owner of the car in the same transaction
transfers a digital token back to me,
and that digital token unlocks the car.
So now I,
I execute the transaction.
The owner receives bitcoin.
I received the digital token, I get
into the car, I pushed the start button.
And because it can recognize that I have
that digital token, the car says, Oh,
you're my new owner. Welcome. I
strive away from getting hacked.
Well, that's the beauty of it. The
security isn't in the phone, right?
That's what the bitcoin network does.
It offers completely
decentralized security.
So in order for the Bitcoin to be
received by the owner and the token to be
transferred to me, that transaction has
to be verified by the bitcoin network.
And that bitcoin network puts an enormous
amount of computation behind it to
make sure it's secure.
Who's running that network?
All of the participants.
So like right now when you did this car
thing, yes. How long ago did you does,
this was in June. Um, you said to take
about 45 minutes for everything to,
it took 45 minutes to settle. I saw
the transaction, instant seconds,
right seconds.
And then I needed to make sure
that it couldn't be reversed.
So this is like for example,
when you deposit a check that
your balance updates immediately,
but it takes three to five days to settle.
In bitcoin,
it takes six confirmations, which is
60 minutes of on average. In my case,
it took about 45 it was run.
Network is running a bit fast that day.
So when that happens you say everyone on
the network that you're talking about,
all the people that are mining bitcoin,
all the people that are mining
bitcoin or participating in securing it
and everybody else in the network also
independently fireflies it.
So after 60 minutes everyone on the
global bitcoin network knew that that
bitcoin for the car was now mine
and that is done. How like what
is the, the actual process,
what is it that goes through?
So you, you get the Bitcoin,
it goes onto your phone,
then it gets verified. What's
happening? How's it getting
the network verifies is it verifies that
bitcoin was transferred to an address
that I control and in that transaction
does a signature by the original owner
and that signature transfers an existing
chain of bitcoin and the network
verifies that the bitcoin that they're
transferring to me exists and has not
been spent and has already
been recognized by the network.
So it's basically building
a backwards chain.
My bitcoin exists because it was properly
signed from a piece of bitcoin that
the person who sent it to me existed,
which was properly signed
by the previous owner,
which was probably signed
by the previous owner.
You go back in time back to the point
where that bitcoin was mined for the first
time and because the network
validates that entire chain,
once it's validated it,
now I can spend it because I can sign it
over to someone else and they can trust
that that bitcoin is good.
Wow. And, and it's some complex
math, but you know, here's the point.
If I tried to explain to you how
a webpage lows on your browser,
I would have to spend 20
minutes describing the border
gateway protocol routing
algorithms a takes the TCP Ip packets
at your browser sentence uses the Ip
address to recognize the global route,
also known as an autonomous system and
based on the subnets of that autonomous
system sends that packet to the nearest
routing system where a routing table
routes it to the next router,
etc. Until it arrives at the web
server that the points being,
you don't see any of that.
Not only that,
I would still not get it and I would
just nod and pretend to understand what
you're saying. Like a dog, you're showing
card tricks too. It's the between using
the technology and understanding
exactly how it works.
The truth is most people don't
even know how to grow a cucumber,
let alone how web server work.
Well,
even if they know how to grow cucumber,
they probably have no idea what is going
on inside the cucumber that's turning a
seed into a piece of vegetable.
But you can still lead it and you can
still use a web browser and you can still
know the simple rule,
which is this after six confirmations
of my bitcoin transaction,
I can trust that I've got that
money in my, in my account done.
So at that point I can give
the key over even better.
If you take that to the Bitcoin
to dot Oh smart property,
my car can recognize that it has a new
owner after six confirmation that the car
itself can independently calculate.
And say this transaction,
the transferred my title as a car to
a new owner has had six confirmations.
Therefore I have a new owner and
if that owner shows up with a key,
I will drive them away.
I will start my engine for them.
And now the property itself,
the asset is smart enough to
track its owners through a chain.
And that means it's,
it's much,
much harder to steal that car.
Is this
thing that the car owner or
the car dealers are creators
of the cars would have
to implement their own operating system?
Where would,
would this be using the same big coin
operating system inside the actual car for
it to recognize you wouldn't be,
yeah. You would be using the blog.
You would replace the part where
the car recognizes a specific key.
Hang on a second.
Yeah.
I have a little key that when I get in
my car knows you've got this kind of,
this key actually has an RFID chip or
some other challenge response mechanism in
it.
So instead of the ignition
system interrogating this key,
the ignition system would interrogate
an ownership record on the bitcoin
blockchain. When you, when
you see something like apple
pay with the thumbprint,
print security and stuff like that,
do you see in the future of bitcoin
adopting some of those kind of McQueen can
to NFC already so it can already
do the same thing as apple pay?
The big differences,
you're not putting 300 million credit
cards into the ownership of a single
company that Jennifer
Lawrence is the picture.
Right? Right. Yeah, so so
exactly. I mean that's,
that represents a systemic risk and
that risk has nothing to do with whether
apple is good at what they do or not.
It has to do with the fact that
credit cards are broken by design.
The fact that the number on a credit card
that you give to every merchant allows
them to go back into your account or
anybody who grabs that can go back into
your account.
That's a broken design.
Essentially what you're doing is think
of your credit card as a password and
you're telling the password to everyone.
When you buy something,
you giving people a key. Yeah,
exactly. A key to your house. Right.
Whereas bitcoin is fundamentally different
because when you sign the transaction,
if they they can't change that transaction
and all they can do is take that
amount for that payment.
Well that was one of the issue of banking
online or doing anything online
was a huge deal just a decade ago.
Like anybody would talk about buying.
Like I used to buy things online in the
early two thousands and people would
look at me like I was crazy.
I got buy a tee shirt online,
use your credit card online.
But because it depends on a centralized
model of trust where you have to trust
each intermediary in the chain.
That's one of the magic things here,
which is that on a credit
card, if I transmit my credit
card from here to there,
that has to be encrypted,
then that system transmits
it to a merchant processing
system is that connection
has to be encrypted.
Then the mulch and pro serve transmits
it to the originating bank that has to be
encrypted.
Everybody keeps a copy of that credit
card number on a database that has to be
encrypted surrounded by firewalls and
monitor it 24 seven because otherwise
target home depot, Jpmorgan Chase,
you know, again and again and again,
we see these hacks.
When I transmit a bitcoin transaction,
there's nothing secrets in it.
I can transmit it over unencrypted Wifi,
I can send it over Bluetooth,
I can play it as a music tone.
I can send it to as a series of Skype
Smiley's that's my latest example.
I can encode a bitcoin transaction is
15 emoticons and Skype and send it.
It doesn't want any one cause
it's you just send it as a song.
Like you could send someone $1 million
in bitcoin through a song. Yes.
So that send them pink Floyd's money and
have bitcoin $1 million in bitcoin and
coded. It's just a message. The
message itself can't be stolen.
So,
so that's the beauty of it.
Now there's a protocol
for phones called Chirp,
which converts data into a sound.
And you can go into a store that supports
Chirp and there are implementations of
Bitcoin for Chirp where you go up to the
merchant and you press a button on your
bitcoin wallet and it goes,
and that's your payment.
That should always go to do doom,
doom, doom, doom, doom, doom,
doom instead of a cat sound. Hey,
well, yeah, it's a little modem. It's,
it's like a modem, right? You remember
the old modem? Oh yeah. Screeching. Yeah,
exactly. So 1414 14.4 bought.
I have one of those bitches.
Well,
schools sending money where you don't
need to encrypt the money means that you
can transmit it over anything.
So you've got,
you've opened up all of the communication
media. When the merchant receives it,
they don't need to protect it because
if they have a bunch of bitcoin
transactions on the database,
those are the same bitcoin transactions
that are on the public ledger.
I don't need to go to the march.
I could look them up on the public ledger.
There's nothing secret about them.
Everybody knows what they are and
so you don't have to hide them.
They can't be forged,
they can't be stolen.
There's no information by the consumer
transmitted that that actually becomes,
I mean, correct me if I'm wrong, I may
be thinking about this incorrectly,
but if someone sends you like say like
you know that u two album that got
stuffed
into everybody's Iphone,
if somebody sends you an album,
those songs themselves,
you can have those songs have the actual
value of the song embedded as bitcoin.
Like it could be a thing that you have
and instead of it being something you can
copy, money has content, but
you what I'm saying? Yes.
If it's completely embedded and
intertwined, if they're symbiotic,
if this is,
it's something that cannot be copied.
Like you can't take like say the big
issue with digital downloads is that you
make an album and someone rips your album,
puts it online and anybody
can make an infinite copies.
But if it's digital money incorporated
into the actual song itself and that
cannot be done, well, no, you should.
Individual one would be something that
is unique and unto itself is that,
does that make any sense?
Possibly.
Although you could probably just strip
out the music and then copy just the
music sound. That's like DRM,
right? Yeah, exactly. It's like DRM.
Soso Diarra it's not really useful for
Drm, right? Um, but it, but it is, uh,
but you can now embed money as a
content type. So people who say,
you know, we're going to stop bitcoin
transactions from being transmitted.
A bitcoin transaction is 250
bytes of information. Um,
Skype has a 128 Smiley emoticons.
That means I can confer to
bitcoin transaction to 16
smileys and as long as you
have the same code on the other end
to convert them back to a bitcoin
transaction and you have
access to a bitcoin network,
I can send you as a 15 Smiley's. You can
take them, turn them into transaction,
put them on the network,
and that transaction will go through.
So it's a kind could be living,
it's a code.
I could be living in the most oppressive
country in the world and as long as I
can transmit 15 Smiley's across my border
or a s or 24 words in English or some
pixels in a picture or a
slight modification of the
red coloration of the Mona
Lisa in a Jpeg,
I can transmit money.
Whoa.
Porn can be money.
Any information can be any information.
You can put a song in a picture,
you can put a picture in a song,
you can put a video in a, did
you see what I mean? So now,
so now money is one more
type of information that can
be transmitted across any
communication medium if that can
support the transmission of information.
Cause I was an issue that we were having
with uploading things to iTunes and
including the image of the actual
pot, the podcast image itself. Right.
We have an issue with that.
Yeah. Order MP three players didn't
understand extra information. Right?
They didn't understand the, the digital
and information on the photograph of the,
you know, the, the cover or
cover art. Right. Which is a
matter of simply being able,
having the rights in coding and decoding
the two ends of the transaction. But,
um, yeah. Here, here's
another really cool one.
You can now create a bitcoin wallet as
represented by either 12 or 24 words from
an an English dictionary
specific dictionary. It has,
I don't remember how many words it has.
I think it's like several thousand words,
specific dictionary of words where each
word has a specific number and without
dictionary.
If you have that dictionary,
which you can download as a
pdf and it's exists online,
12 words create a bitcoin wallet.
So it's not just a matter of
transmitting a single transaction.
You can transfer the entire
contents of your wallet or backups,
your Wallet as 12 English
words. So now, potato,
asparagus, army, caravan, door, carpet,
screwdriver,
lemon.
FICUS is a wallet.
And if I say those 12 words to
someone who knows that it's a wallet,
they can take that to recreate
not just one transaction,
but all of the transaction,
all of the addresses,
all of the money that's in that wallet.
I can transfer the entire account or
millions of accounts on the same system in
12 words. That's fucking insane.
Can I put those 12 words?
I could spray paint them on the wall.
I could put them on a poster.
I could transmit them.
Now obviously that's a secret
you don't want to tell everybody,
but I could just simply send you a
book and then send you a series of
coordinates, you know, page 35
second word, first paragraph,
and now you have a bitcoin
wallet to the form of a book.
It's incredible.
You could send me a photograph like
you could be on vacation and send me a
photograph and the bitcoin
money could be embedded in that.
The information of that photograph being
sent to someone else's phone in just a
slight hue variation in the
red coloration of a photo. Yes,
that's a more, any of the colors. You
could just modify a couple of the pixels.
You can do that with anything.
Now if you have that code,
it's just like Morse code.
It's called steganography.
It's its secret writing
within some other form.
And it's been done for Ashley for a
very long time. For centuries. Well,
that was an issue with a,
supposedly with Osama bin Laden and
how they were transferring information
online through, we're doing it through
jpegs. Right. Wasn't that like a,
one of the big ways to do or yes.
Among others.
I think they use it actually
the first people to do
do this war Franciscan monks who,
who would write, uh, you know,
copies of the Bible and that they'd
write it so that the first letter of each
sentence vertically
spelled something else.
So they put a hidden message within
the Bible. Right. So it goes,
it goes back a bit further than us.
Some I've been loud as some part of
what the Da Vinci Code is based on.
I got a secret writing as is
another dart. Well, I mean,
that's essentially how they got
away with transferring information during
the World War One and World War II era.
Right. When they were like Dee Dee
Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee, they had a,
they had a deep code.
A lot of what they're morse code was,
would they were actually saying,
yeah,
all that I knew. But for whatever
reason, this has blown me away.
This idea of taking information and
betting it in either a song or photograph
and that becoming a bitcoin transaction.
Yeah, that's freaking me out.
And you could put it anywhere. You could
put a bitcoin transaction into anything.
Um,
so for example,
imagine if you have an oppressive
government and they're trying to block all
external internet.
How about the Keisha?
And imagine if you don't,
is there,
is there a fucking government that isn't
oppressive anymore? Okay? You know,
I mean, everyone's, imagine
an oppressive government.
Imagine one that's completely banned,
all Internet rights,
and you've shut down the internet and
you want to do bitcoin transactions in
that country. You're really
motivated, right to you. You,
you want to buy spray cans to spray
your revolutionary message on the wall.
That's, let's use an a
nonviolence example. Okay? Um,
so now what you can do is as long as
you have a country next door that has a
shortwave receiver with someone
willing to put messages on the Bitcoin
blockchain,
you could transmit a bitcoin transaction
over short wave with like morse,
with a radio, and you could
do it in a matter of seconds.
So you could make your entire
transmission in 25 seconds.
So now you start going into,
they did this in France
during the Nazi occupation,
the allies drop tens of thousands of
shortwave radios with parachutes to the
participant resistance, the French
resistance and the participants would
go out into the middle of
the woods, hookup there,
radio antenna to a rail line,
a railroad line, a long piece of
steel that acts as an antenna,
burst the short wave transmission and
transmit for a few minutes, disconnect,
disappearance of the woods.
And there's no way you can find
them or stop them or do that.
Then I could do that with money.
Wow.
That is fucking wild.
That's a boy.
That's something I never
even took into consideration.
And that's something once money starts
being adopted by more and more companies
and more and more people started using
it for more and more transactions,
that's something that could
be real paradigm shifting.
There's a,
I mean that's the,
this is the idea of the rabbit hole.
You know,
bitcoins is,
at first it strikes you as something
very simplistic gets a series of digital
information.
It's some numbers and you send them
and you and you make a transaction.
So it's money as email. Okay, fine. But
then if you go deeper and you see the,
the way it's structured
without knowing intermediaries,
the way it works is a
decentralized network.
The way it turns money into information,
the more you think about it,
the more you go down the rabbit hole,
the more you realize that structures and
constraints that exist today are wiped
away or blown away by this thing
and it opens up these possibilities.
And the really interesting ones
are the ones we can't imagine.
The ones that are not an extension of
what we do today but are completely novel
have never happened.
But in the sense that it parallels the
Internet itself in that regard. Right,
and that's the main argument I'm trying
to make that this is not money for the
Internet. This is the
internet of money. Whoa.
It is a platform on top of which
you can build applications.
Currency is just the first APP.
There will be more apps,
there'll be stock ops and fallen
gaps and a smart property apps.
Okay, so to use the internet as an
analogy, like what year are we in?
We in the 1995 of the Internet,
I I, my estimate has been
consistent over the last year.
I've been talking about this being the
1992 to 1994 period they have to face is
a pretty rough,
the major paradigm shifting companies
and innovations haven't happened yet.
The web hasn't happened where the,
we're still on Ip addresses
is that of DNS names.
That's why the Bitcoin is
restful interface hasn't
been developed yet. Right.
It's gnarly. It's weird.
It's esoteric, it's Geeky.
Most people haven't heard about it.
The big money hasn't come in,
but all of the technology
potential is already there.
And the adoption has
already reached technology,
critical mass meaning that uh,
someone said recently at the conference,
we're not the early adopters
where the lunatic fringe,
the early adopters come later.
I got to turn higher primary
Dotcom, Bitcoin, I'm writing
a note cause he's a paypal.
You may be able to, you might be able
to just do it by turning on paypal now,
um, I don't know if their Beta
program is, is ready for that,
but it's not that the Falcon Bard is sons
of bitches and I'm going to get on on
in as well kept on it to start drilling.
I can't do anything about comedy
central about my new special,
but those things I can do something,
I dunno man. You have, you,
you have as a content creator,
I think you'll find that a publishers
are open to new exciting and it's,
I'm out their ideas,
I think you have the opportunity to go
chat with some of them and say, Hey,
you don't want to try something new.
I've definitely have a chat to them.
And then they get,
oh,
there's that fucking pothead cage fighting
commentator idiot who's covered in
tattoos. Let's just not listen to him and
keep making millions. Get out of here,
kid.
They're not going to listen to me.
That's certainly a familiar sentiment
for me because I felt that before you can
now pump gas for bitcoin in the rocky
mountains. Powerful rocky mountains.
Where is this that's happening?
Uh,
it's the Colorado in Greeley, Colorado,
of course called the cosmic market.
Well, you know, it's interesting. Greeley,
Colorado is one of those
towns that doesn't want
marijuana there. Those fucking,
there's
one of the towns is trying
to keep marijuana out. See
how well, you know, the,
they're worried that it's going to be a
bunch of hooligans and Ne'er do wells.
Meanwhile, that has changed
Colorado in a goddamn traumatic way.
It was beautiful being back there and
seeing all the businesses that are
spawning out of this, this legalized
marijuana movement. And again,
it's another, it's another example of
what happens when you give people freedom.
You know, can you buy pot with
bitcoin? Goddamn revolutionary. Really?
Oh absolutely. Cause la speed, we'd
use bit coin, you know, I don't know.
She needs to get on that shit.
You could buy gas cards also a coin,
fuel.com you can buy any
kind of gas cards. Yeah.
Any kind of gas card with bitcoin.
Look at the, did you know about this?
So the real question now is can you buy
x with bitcoin directly or can you buy x
with Bitcoin?
Fire an intermediary.
That's the only difference cause you can
pretty much buy anything with bitcoin.
Now the question is how
many conversions do you do?
Do you need to convert bitcoin into a
currency or a gift card or a report point
miles or something else? Cysto or
some kind of customer loyalty program?
Or does someone else buy the product
for you and you'll give them bitcoin and
intermediary? Or can you give
bitcoin to the merchant directly?
So there's all of these shades, right?
But in terms of Kenyan by x with Bitcoin,
the answer is yes, there's an escort
for bitcoin time still not open yet.
Escort for bitcoin daughter trying
to figure it out. Meanwhile,
those are some digital bitches
are very shady. There's, you know,
those are undercover cops
because they're like,
why would they go through
the exter? Like, Hey,
we're going to make it only bitcoin
guy trying to crash gamergate. I Dunno.
This is the, there'll be the
first digital STDs that you get.
We'll get into your bitcoin wallet.
Fuck it all up.
I think it's amazing. I mean,
since you started coming on here,
which was a over a year ago,
the very first appearance,
we've seen quite a shift in
the accessibility of bitcoin.
The ability to buy things with bitcoin.
The, the people, uh, accepting Bitcoin,
the acceptibility and the discussion of
Bitcoin is escalated. It's, it's elevated.
I think that discussion is less about,
I think there's less ignorance and
less just blatant misrepresentation.
So a here,
regardless having these discussions and
people were asking questions like, well,
why cans touching a Komodo? Just come
in and take all the bitcoin and um,
you know, won't this only be used by
terrorists and pornographers? My people.
And you know, that was the, that was the
conversation. Now we've elevated a bear.
So the funny thing is that people are are
beginning to recognize that they can't
simply dismiss bitcoin out of hand.
So what they do is they tried to split
hairs that like, yeah, well you know,
the technology of the blockchain
is really fascinating, but bitcoin,
the currency will obvious obviously fail.
So they're splitting hairs.
Now give him another year, we're
going to come around. Of course, those
of us who have been in this for a while
on the stand that the technology and the
currency,
our goal like hand in hand,
you can't have a successful technology
without a valuable currency and vice a
versa,
but you're beginning to see the naysayers
tried to split hairs because they can
no longer say there's nothing there. They
can no longer say this is just a joke.
Because many,
many very smart,
intelligent, well educated, well
informed people are saying, hang on,
this isn't a joke. There is something
interesting about this technology.
There's something disruptive about this
technology and we're looking into it's
seriously and after you see a bunch of,
you know,
we shouldn't do appeal by authority,
this should stand on its own.
It either is or it isn't,
but the truth is that in our culture,
we do appeal by authority.
When paypal comes along and says,
there's something here and we're
going to invest in at overstock, Dell,
tiger direct, you know,
one after the other.
These companies turn around
your, you say, well, you know,
these are not dumb people. These are
not people who don't understand money.
These are not the lunatic fringe anymore.
They're the early adopters and
the conversation has changed.
Do you remember when we did our first
show? Apple banned bitcoin applications?
Yes. They reverted that four
months ago. Five months ago.
They had to change their stance and now
there are dozens of bitcoin wallets.
I predicted that they would switch their,
predict that,
but I've read that the reason why they
did was because there was some fuckery
involved in the actual coding
of the software itself and
that they weren't being
entirely accurate about what the software
was capable of doing. Oh, there was a,
I mean when they were being very
difficult about bitcoin applications,
a lot of the bitcoin applications,
we're kind of trying to find
loopholes here and there.
One of the funniest I saw was that apple
had a whole different set of rules.
If you have a co op,
so if you have a co op,
you can distribute software to your club
members without putting it through the
apple iTunes store.
So someone set up a bitcoin wallet
that's you sign up by email to become a
member of the co op and they
said the APP by email, right?
So people were doing all kinds
of shenanigans like that.
But really the real reason for this,
and we said that six months ago was apple
was going to launch apple pay and they
didn't need a whole bunch of insurgent
little Weirdo applications earnings,
their announcement.
So until the last moment they resisted,
they wanted to keep control over payments,
both in store payments where they make
a very healthy 30% cots on every APP and
every in store purchase.
And they wanted to introduce their
own payments and wallet technology.
And so they did that.
So now apple has created compuserve
and we still have the intranet.
Now we can play on a level playing field.
Let's see who wins.
I have my bets on the Internet. Not you
serve of money. That's what I propel.
That's what apple pay does,
right?
They have a number of 300 million
credit cards subscribers who have the
steroidal curated walled
garden controlled experience.
And then there's bitcoin. The works
internationally that is wide open.
That doesn't do all of that. I have
my credit cards on my, my wallet.
I used it the other day for my first time.
This is the apple pay apple pay thing.
Jamie,
can you get some whiskey and ice?
I'm trying to do something with my voice
here. Put it in the microwave. Hello. No,
no, I don't want, I want it cold. That's
why I fuck put it in the microwave. Yeah,
it's good for your throat. Warm
Melt. The ice. Who are you?
So when you, when you use this, did
it, did it do anything? It was just,
you just kind of swiped it
over the thing and it just,
you only certain vendors that works on
you can't, you can't do it everywhere,
right?
It's any of the credit card machines
where you usually swipe your own card. Uh,
most of the newer ones
have a little symbol on it.
That means it has the little Wifi as
this remote control Nis or whatever it's
called, right? That's NFC as
pay waste system or tap and pay.
Now here's the interesting thing.
Apple launched apple pay and Google,
which has Google wallet,
had seen very few subscribers and
as soon as apple pay launched,
Google subscriber numbers shot through
the roof because you can do the same
thing on android and I'm really banking
on that effect because apple will will
make people familiar with mobile wallets,
the idea of tap and pay with their thing,
but they still have many
of the same problems.
Apple has all of these credit
cards that have vulnerable,
they track all of your purchases and
everything you do and they're going to
impose restrictions on what the things
you can pay and what merchants you can
pay and you've still got all of
the old players, visa, mastercard,
American Express, all of the problematic
payment networks that are restrictive.
They have $5 minimums.
They're very expensive for
merchants. You can have fraud,
all of these things,
but what they're doing is
they're familiarizing people
with PE and NFC and we
can do that with bitcoin too.
Only we can give them the full experience
from micropayments to cross border
transactions to countries they've
never heard of to you know,
the full bitcoin experience.
I see what you say.
It's compuserve versus the
intranet or compuserve and AOL.
Internet's golf people. Anybody
who wants do you want some of this?
Got People used to the idea of email in
a safe kind of curated environment like
a sandbox and once they did what they
really wanted was the full internet email
because the open technology
innovates faster.
It has broader scale is less fragile
and it has more participation.
And so same thing applies to bitcoin.
Do you think iPhone is going to be the
platform of choice for the four to 6
billion unbanked people in Indonesia
and the Philippines in Subsaharan Africa
and South Africa and Latin America?
Hell No.
It's going to be android with bitcoin.
It's not going to be apple pay.
And that's fine because apple pay has a
role to play and will familiarize people
with this technology and get people
to start thinking of money as a purely
digital thing.
And then we come along and we deploy
bitcoin on $20 android phones and saturate
the rest of the world. Um, and give them
that experience and it was such passion.
I say that with passion,
right? The rest of the world.
But 5 billion people having international
banking for the first time in history
I in that gives me shivers a it is,
it is.
That is the most revolutionary
aspect of this technology.
It's not making like right now,
instead of swiping my card,
I can wave my phone.
I've saved 150 calories in my
consumer spending experience.
That's bullshit.
That doesn't do anything for anyone.
But you allow someone who's never
done banking before to send money
internationally to get loans from anywhere
in the world to start a company and
sell a product anywhere in the world.
And to do that for 4 billion people,
5 billion people, 6 billion people,
that stuff changes the world.
It's not going to be
about shopping. No, no.
It's going to be about getting rid of
the existing sis system that many people
find, but they don't have an existing
system. Pressive but I mean in, in this,
you know, and in the third world
you're talking about in the,
in the second and third wall, so
this, according to the World Bank,
there's two and a half billion
people who are unbanked.
That means they have no banking
facilities whatsoever. No money.
They can't deposit stones. No,
not true. They live in a cash.
They live in cash and barter based
societies. They do have money.
They exchange labor products and services
with each other all the time. Eggs,
chickens, beans, farming, carrying
water, whatever it may be,
post apocalyptic type money and they
have an enormous productive potential.
But barter makes it very difficult
to trade. Barter. If you,
if the other person wants chickens
and you have a goat, yeah,
you got to give a lot of fucking chicken.
You've got to find
someone who wants a goat.
And so and so what that does is that you
have a very high friction economy and
it reduces everybody's
productivity to do anything.
You have to walk 10 20 miles to transact.
Now these people have productive capacity
and that's the two and a half billion.
Then there's another three and a
half billion people who have banking,
but it's very basic banking, which means
it's uh, in their own currency only.
No international markets, no credits,
all liquidity, no credit history,
no ability to wire money.
And their,
their nearest bank branch
is usually fairly far away.
So they primarily use it for savings.
They don't use it to do, you know,
point of sale, visa swiping,
debit cards and things like that.
And together these two constituencies,
these two populations, many of them have
cell phones, they have text messaging,
cell phones.
So you bring together those
two technologies and you
can create essentially a
revolution and financial,
um,
economic inclusion in international trade
and productivity where instead of now
walking 15 miles the market, you can
do a transaction on your cell phone.
Well, especially since all that money
is interchangeable international.
Yes, it's all, yes, it's all the same.
This happened in Kenya and Kenya
in 2001 at local phone companies,
safari calm,
one of the telcos in that space created
a program where people could exchange
cell phone minutes with
each other. And so, um,
that system initially started
being used informally as money.
So people would be like, give me eggs,
I'll give you two cell phone minutes.
Because it was equivalent to money.
People couldn't afford
to have a bank account,
but they could afford to
have a cell phone contract.
This is how messed up the banking
system is. It around the world.
And so they would exchange
minutes for products and services.
Eventually the phone company a couple
of years later recognize that they call
this thing empaysah for mobile peso,
which is the currency of Kenya
and they started broadening it to,
it now spends three or four
countries in the region.
Here's what happened 11 years later and
Pesa is 40% of the GDP of Kenya for 0%
40 and this is not GDP that got
converted from Paysa to Empaysah.
Most of this is completely new economic
activity that previously existed does
gray markets,
barter markets,
cash only societies and was inefficient
and slow so it actually generated growth
and economic activity in this country.
We've seen this happen in one country.
You can't transfer and
pace outside the country.
You can't use it for a mitten says it's
specific to one currency and it's still
heavily taxed and manipulated.
Now imagine what we could do with bitcoin.
No, a few months back there
was some controversy online
and you made a statement
that you were resigning from
some sort of organization. Yeah.
What was that all about?
Well,
there's,
there's an organization which is kind
of like a membership association called
the Bitcoin Foundation and it sounds so,
a lot of people that this organization
has some kind of role or authority.
They really don't. It's just a
member association. Right. Um,
they don't control bitcoin. They don't
have any role to play in the code.
Uh, they do collect money from members
and they use that money to pay some of the
main developers so that they can focus
full time on bitcoin. Like a foundation,
for example, a Mozilla that makes
Firefox, they have foundation,
they pay a lot of developers. Linux,
the operating system has a foundation,
pays a lot of developers. So
it's kind of like that. Um,
but they don't have any
control over anything.
They just collect member Jews
and they do some law being,
they do some public relations,
they pay some developers.
I had some problems with the transparency
and the way the organization was being
run.
I,
I participated in the early days
in the election process. Uh,
I helped with that.
I was one of the people moderating
the debates between Ferris candidates,
was hoping to see some reform,
some of the original members and some
of the charter and the rules were such
that it was highly, highly compromised
from the beginning. And for example,
uh, one of the founding members
is mark was Mark Carr Palace,
the guy who owns and crashed Mt.
Gox.
He was one of the founders and the
bigger the big fat face, right?
So when you have like two or three of
the directors in that facing massive
lawsuits were indictments or still alive,
it seems like some didn't like a lot of
money vanished with hundreds of billions
of dollars and he's like running around
buying noodles at a market. Right.
He can go anywhere he wants. I'll put
that down to the fact that Japan has very,
very effective gun control. Oh, does
that, the reason why I, you know,
I mean I'm a pacifist side.
I would like to thank the,
what should happen to him is we should
have a full and proper accounting of what
happens and then he should
pay the appropriate price
through the judicial system.
Well that's impossible though. I mean,
the amount of money that you would have,
I mean he would have to generate
some ungodly, never. No,
people are never going to get
paid back for the money they lost.
But at least you could see at
first truth then just form,
you need the truth first. Like let's at
least find out what actually happened.
People need to know that somehow or
another for folks who don't understand the
situation or are not aware
of it. Mt. Gox was about,
so it was an exchange. It would buy and
sell bitcoins for us. Dollar is cheap,
Japanese yen and euros.
And it was the first exchange.
So it was the first place where you could
trade your bitcoins for something else.
But it was originally, it was established
from a website that was about magic,
the gathering, right?
Correct. It was for trading,
playing cards because they ha they
already had the market based trading
mechanism, so they just converted it to
Bitcoin, which was a very smart move,
but it wasn't up to the, to the
job. Um, what is it a scenario,
sorry to interrupt you,
but it was,
it was a scenario where the landscape
had changed so quickly. Yes. So,
so radically that they couldn't keep up
and they couldn't possibly have foreseen
it when they started trading trading
bitcoin and then it just got out of hand,
uh, among other things. Yes.
So how responsible would a person
be in that sort of scenario? Well,
there's more than gross
incompetence there.
And I for a long time thought it was
just an incredible amount of incompetence
and lack of due diligence. Oh, so
now there's, there's evidence. Well,
there's the classic evidence where,
and mistaken certain problems caused money
to be lost and then instead of coming
clean about that,
but we know now knows that car Pellis
continued to run the operation where he
would pain old customers out from the
money coming in from new customers.
That's the definition of a Ponzi scheme.
And most Ponzi schemes don't
start because someone says,
let me run a Ponzi scheme.
They start because they start
trading customer's money,
they lose too much and they don't want
to admit that they lost the money,
so they start using the new customer's
money to pay off the old customers.
The lies get bigger,
the numbers get bigger until one day
the lies and the numbers get too big to
hide at all comes out in the open and
collapses. That's exactly what happened.
The lesson to learn from Mt Gox is when
you have a decentralized secure solution
like bitcoin and you give all
of the keys to one person,
what happens is exactly what has happened
for the last several thousand years of
history.
That person takes the money in rugs.
Yeah.
You've said on the podcast previously
that you think it's probably a good thing
that this crashed and it's a good lesson
for the rest of the bitcoin community.
It's a very painful lesson. I wish
people had been able to learn it. I mean,
a lot of people were blowing the whistle
long before a collapse and saying,
including myself saying,
do not put your money in this system.
And in many ways highlights the positive
attributes at bitcoin shared peer to
peer,
the way it's being done right now.
Awesome. So you know, the expression,
possession is nine tenths
of the law in Bitcoin.
Possession is 10 tenths of the law.
If you have the keys, it's your money.
If you don't have the keys,
it's not your money.
And people did not control the keys.
It's Gox.
They gave them to cart palace anyway,
so people get assessed.
Just to wrap this up, I
resigned from that, uh,
association saying I wanted to,
I tried to make it,
you know,
I don't want to make a big deal out of it.
I just say I disagree with the
way this is being managed. Then.
I like the transparency. It hasn't
been reformed enough. I'm out.
It was turned into a very big news story.
Um,
I'm hoping that nothing bad
happens within the foundation,
but I still have concerns that
because of a lack of transparency,
because of a lack of reform that could
be opportunities there for shenanigans.
When is the best resource besides
listening to you on podcasts,
which is excellent for people to research
bitcoin to find out where they could
get more information, where they given,
assimilate into maybe a community,
a message board where
they can exchange ideas.
So there's, there's a couple of really
good, uh, sites where you can go on CE.
Uh, Lauren thinks about bitcoin.
bitcoin.org is one of those,
uh, it has information about how to get
into bitcoin. What it is that's run a,
again by an Association of users
is a nonprofit style thing.
It's one of the things that bitcoin
foundation does relatively well,
and you can find information
about bitcoin there. Um,
there's various online communities and
massive community on Facebook. I'm really,
really, I'm very excited about
the meetup community meetup.com,
uh, local grassroots, uh, meetups all
around the world. So when I go speaking,
like I went to Australia, I went to
the Sydney meetup group and I said,
tell all your members, let's have a
meetup. I'll come talk about bitcoin.
And they gathered, they sold out
250 seats in a room like instantly.
So these things didn't exist a year ago.
The wall where there weren't enough
bitcoin in one place to get together.
Now there are in hundreds
of places around the world.
So meetup.com go and meet people who
are into bitcoin and learn about it.
They're also meetups for bitcoin
developers to learn how to do software
development. And I started one of those
in San Francisco with the second, uh,
of that type and one of
the most successful and now
has more than 600 members I
believe. And I'm going to do a very
brief but shameless plug. How dare you?
Um,
on December 27th or Riley media,
which is a software and
development publisher,
technical publisher is publishing my book.
It's called mastering bit coin.
And it's a book for software
developers to learn how to use bitcoin.
I spent a year and a half working
on that and just finished.
I got an email this morning
that final copy went to print,
so I'm actually going to be a
book book or it's a book as well.
It's a digital book. It's a
print book cover. I, I'm, I'm,
I should be a,
I'm trying to get Morgan
Freeman to read the [inaudible].
I'll read it with my weird Greek British
accents. You're going to read it, right?
I don't know. I don't know if this
is going to be an audio. It's,
it's a technical book.
It's got cold segments in it.
It's not exactly geared to
be an audio book, but, okay.
We'll see ebook print. Um, it's
also on an open source license.
I'm a huge believer in open source. I use
the creative Commons licensing system,
so it's creative Commons with attribution
share, like it's available online.
The entire book was developed online with
contributions from hundreds of people
who corrected things in the book.
All of the editing process was public.
You can download it for free.
It's for free or is there, no,
it's published by a mainstream software
and technical publisher with a lot of
clout who are taking it to a mainstream
audience because we needed that to this
space and that's coming out in
print, Amazon, Barnes and noble,
[inaudible] Dot Com and every other
book publisher and book distributor out
there. We'll have a copy of
this book. You can buy it.
It's 30 to 35 bucks retail,
approximately 28 I think on Amazon you
can buy an Ebook for about $25 and but
it's also available for free online
as a pdf or as that source code.
Kind of crazy.
You're,
you're selling it and you're giving
it away at the same time. Yes,
and I will tell you that has many
have discovered in this space.
Open source content does
not diminish retail sales.
In fact, it grows them. Really? Yes.
The people who can't
afford to buy the book,
we'll buy it to put it on their bookshelf
and have paper reference to put it on
their kindle than a nicely
formatted convenient way.
It's easy. It's convenient.
One Click.
If there is value,
people will pay for
convenience and packaging and,
and just kind of the quality of,
of printed colored paper.
Honestly, they will. Um,
that's why you're drinking a bottle of
water when you can get free water from
the tap because the government
fluoride in black helicopters,
but people pay for quality
and packaging and convenience.
And so at the same time, people who
couldn't afford to buy the book,
uh, we'll download it and use it as
a resource to learn these skills.
And to me that's the most important
thing because if you want to invest in
Bitcoin is you don't invest in the
currency. You invest in the skills.
This is like learning how
to make a website in 2000
is like learning how to make
an Ios app in 2005. This is a
skill that will give you a job and,
and so that's killed. It'll give you
a job. Yeah. Like what kind of job?
We're hiring thousands of people in this
industry in order to do the software
development.
What kind of software development and
we're talking about there are now, um,
some 800 startups being tracked by,
um,
I think it's called venture scan,
which is a company that tracks funded
venture capital funded startups.
There are more than 800 companies in
the space doing startups around Bitcoin,
building applications, user interfaces,
new financial services, exchanges,
wallets, you name it,
someone's building something.
This is a new industry blossoming
and creating thousands of jobs.
And,
and this industry is now hiring thousands
of people in the u s especially with
skills around software development,
accounting, finance, um,
marketing, public relations,
operations management,
the entire spectrum of things
you need in a startup. Wow.
And so this book that you wrote has a lot
of coding and coding instruction in it.
So the first two chapters
are accessible to anyone. Um,
they explain how bitcoin works at
a level that someone who is not,
who is a bit technical but not a program.
I can understand.
The other eight chapters are how bitcoin
works in detail for a programmer to get
a complete soup to nuts overview
of how the entire system,
not just bitcoin,
but the blockchain technology and all of
the other currencies that are based on
that model, how it works,
how to write software to it,
how all the data structures work,
how have the protocols work,
and to get a complete
understanding of it. Uh, so,
so it's really for programmers.
So you,
and you've immersed yourself in this
over the period of x amount of years.
How many years? Three years.
Three years. And what,
what knowledge base of coding did
you have before you got into it?
I started coding when I was 10 years old,
so I'm not a professional programmer.
I'm, I'm, I'm passionate
amateur if you like. I,
I've been paid a few
times for writing code,
but I'm not as productive and disciplined
as a professional coder who only does
coding. Um, I code for fun.
I code because I'm fascinated by it.
And when I started this,
I knew quite a lot about coding,
um,
and a bit about bitcoin. And I
started writing a book, honestly,
the best way to teach yourself at
technologies to try to teach it to someone
else. And I learned more about Bitcoin
by writing the book. And you know,
when I started,
I knew a bit.
Now I know a lot more because I had to
find ways to explain this technology in
simple terms.
You know,
that's so fascinating that you say that
because that's a truism that is a often
expressed in martial arts.
You know,
one of the ways that I got really good
at martial arts is I taught from the time
I was 15 years old, I taught,
I taught at Boston University,
I taught at my own school.
I was,
I used to teach all of the private
lessons at mines. And because of that,
my technique got very clean and
sharp. Right. And I, I think that,
that I've often thought about doing
that with, even with standup comedy,
although I don't think you
really can teach standup comedy,
you can kind of exchange
information and go over the, the,
the facts of it or the, the, the,
the, the building blocks of it.
So I find that really amazing that
you say that about coding as well.
It seems to be chipped Prov
right? Um, not really. Well,
you can teach these people to never do it
again. Okay. I fucking, I needed a genre.
Well, I would sign up. Um,
yeah, it applies to coding.
It applies to book writing. Applies
to, this applies to public speaking.
I'm learning how to be a pilot
now. Um, so I love flying planes.
So it's one of the things I'm really
into and as soon as I'm complete with my
training,
it should be in the next month or so,
I'm going to start the next stage to
become an instructor because if I want to
get really good at that, I need to start
teaching other people how to do it.
It's a truism cross. If you want
to learn something, well teach it.
And maybe at first it's
hard because you in,
in teaching it,
you realize how,
how much you need to learn in
order to be more crisp and to,
to be able to create explanations
that are simple to understand.
You first have to understand
it in depth yourself. Yes.
But it focuses you and so that's,
that was part of how I wrote
the book was I, I understood it,
but I understood it at a relatively
superficial level just to use it in trying
to explain it, I had to learn. It's
a lot deeper. That's, that is so
true and so interesting about knowledge
about information is that a lot of
people develop a cursory or a
working knowledge of something.
But in order to really explain it,
you have to have a full foundation.
You have to have, you know, every,
you have to have the, the blocks,
the structure,
you have to have the whole thing in order
to explain what a house is, you know,
and then that's, that's a, that's a
really amazing thing about information.
It just,
it really fascinates me how the mind
works and how just absorbing information
and the depth of bap absorption. Like
there's some people that I could talk to,
I'm sure that no bitcoin but don't know
bit coin like you and I could have a
conversation with them and come away
with some misconceptions. Perhaps,
but then talking and talking to you,
especially since you teach it so much
and me and essentially what you're doing
when you do podcasts is
you're teaching us what,
what the potential or the future
applications for Bitcoin can be.
And in doing so,
you know,
I get a much deeper sense of what it is
because you're so used to teaching it.
Yeah, and I, I have to say,
you've got to realize there was a lot
of people who know bit coin a hell of a
lot better than I do and know
how to apply it to the fuck.
Are these people well there,
there must be Weirdos. No,
they're all the technical geniuses who
spend most of the time making the bitcoin
code better and building
applications around it.
I'm not a professional coder and I
don't spend most of my time doing that.
It's important to realize what they do is,
is orders of magnitude deeper than
what I do and understand about bitcoin.
But I have one skills.
Yes, I have one skill.
I think that skill is necessary
and valuable and this is what I do.
I took my skill,
which is explaining and teaching and
public speaking and applied it to bitcoin.
And I'm not the most knowledgeable.
I'm not,
not even close to being the
most knowledgeable. Bless.
And what are you missing?
What are you missing a lot of
blogs? Well, first of all, um,
the focus on on code and developing,
I mean, I don't write code,
you know, 24 hours a day. I
don't write code all the time.
They write code all the
time. The Algorithms, um,
issues of scalability and optimization,
understanding the really subtle technical
nuances of the protocol and developing
a consensus protocol. Those
are really subtle. I mean,
you can find tiny,
tiny bugs in Bitcoin,
which under certain conditions,
if you're right to transaction,
was certain script operators that can
cause this to happen and that to happen.
And you've got people who are way out
ahead who are finding these things,
figuring out,
oh,
here's some things that could go wrong
in a transaction and here's some code
that ensures that we check
for that from now on. I mean,
I don't have that depth. I can
understand what they're talking about.
But I wouldn't have figured that out by
myself because I don't spend the time
analyzing the code like they do.
It's one of the weird things about
being a human being. It's just,
it's so cool that there are
so many different people
and that the spectrum is so
broad that there are some just
very bizarre people that are just sitting
in front of a computer just banging
out numbers since staring at lines of
code and those are super important.
If those people weren't here, we wouldn't
be doing this, wouldn't be doing this.
There's no question about it. The
online, can I do no online, right?
What I do by comparison
is a is an afterthought.
It's a layer that only happens because
other people did this work at first.
That's what what really amazes
me about working in this space.
Over the last three years, I have
met some of the sharpest, smartest,
most intelligent,
most incredibly complicated
thinkers in terms of coding,
technology, databases,
protocols, finance, economics,
monetary policy.
Some of the best thinkers of
our generation have fixated
on this little project
and are doing things that are incredible,
and I meet these people and I say,
there's a reason why when smart
people figure out what this is,
they get fixated. They get really,
really obsessed about this technology.
So you go from skeptic.
My first reaction when I came
across bitcoin was nerd money,
like just completely ignored it.
Six months later, I read the paper,
light bulbs start going off
in my head. I'm like, Oh,
distributed control system security model.
This is not just the currency. Wait,
hang on a second.
This is contents.
Now it has these implications and you
just go straight down the rabbit hole.
I went down that rabbit hole so far.
Four months later I had lost more than
20 pounds because I was spending 18 hours
a day reading everything I could
about it. Writing Code, communicating.
I forgot to eat. This has happened
to me three or four times in my life.
That is a particular personality quirk.
I call it.
I call it the state of Fugue fugue.
Feg FEG you,
he,
it's this association with reality and
you can go all the way pathological and
just run into serious
trouble. Um, I did it.
It's on a relatively heavy
basis for most people,
but still survivable my first
computer when I got my first computer.
It just, it's completely transformed
my life. It's, it's opened up,
um, a space of imagination
that I didn't know existed.
And I started programming and I realize
what you could do with programming.
And my mind is a 10 year old just went,
so what year was this?
This was a 1982.
So you got in way early.
It was one of the first,
uh, like before the Atari,
like this was a ZX 81.
Sinclair microcomputer from Britain.
You connected it to your TV,
but you could program this thing and
you could write basic software and you
could even write to assembly code on it.
And within six months,
by the time I was 11, I was writing
assembly code on this thing and,
and I didn't even understand
the mathematics behind it.
I learned those
mathematics in high school,
but I already was practicing that stuff.
When I got my first modem and I connected
to bulletin board systems and Los
Angeles, in fact from Greece
over long distance phone calls.
My family was not happy
about that phone bill. Um,
and I communicated with geeks on
another continent for the first time.
It blew my mind.
I,
I opened the door to an entire reality
that was impossible for a Greek teen to,
to experience. And when I got my
first Internet connection again,
bitcoin is would like one of those events.
And when I first started,
I dismissed it. But when I, when I took a
slightly deeper glimpse and I saw where,
what it was straight down the rabbit hole,
forgot to eat for four months,
lost a ton of weight, just became
completely obsessed completely.
I mean,
you know,
you go out for dinner with your friends
and you bring up bitcoin in every single
conversation and before long you're
not invited to dinner anymore.
Um, but after that I managed
to find a more healthy balance.
Um, I'm still absolutely
fascinated about this technology.
I don't forget to eat anymore.
I'm still fascinated by as technology.
And every day I learned something that
opens up even more the possibilities.
And, and now I'm not longer thinking,
well, can we do in two years?
And now I'm thinking this is still going
to be changing things two decades from
now, three decades from now. Wow.
Well listen dude, I was like,
you are very important,
really crazy fucks that will not eat
for months at a time and lose 18 pounds
because you find the viability and
the potential in something like this,
it's very important.
The world didn't change because
someone who was already an established
researcher in an established space
made a tiny incremental change.
The world has changed numerous times
because someone from the lunatic fringe
refuse to accept that their idea was
stupid and crazy and would never work and
persevered regardless and end
adopt changing an entire industry.
When Einstein was a patent worker in the
Australian patent office or Swiss paths,
that office, I don't remember even, um,
he wasn't part of the physics community.
He was the lunatic fringe. And he came
up with an idea that was ridiculed,
uh, for a good decade before
anybody figured out that
there was something there,
right? Um, and we see the same
thing in history again and again.
We rewrite and whitewash the
history of innovation to say,
and then Ford created the
car and everyone went,
good job forward. We'll all
buy model t's. No, they didn't.
What they said was, you car
enthusiasts, you're insane.
This is crazy. It's, it's noisy.
It will destroy our roads.
It will never work.
When Edison discovered and created all
of these wonderful things around the
electricity, people didn't
say, that's amazing.
Let's all electrify
everything the media said.
Anybody who puts electricity in
their house will burn it down.
And only the rich and crazy would dabble
in this technology and it will soon go
away and pass as a fad.
And why don't you use traditional
good working kerosene?
Well,
that's what he said about everything.
If that's what they said about
everything, it takes the, it takes.
The people who refuse to accept
the vision they're seeing is crazy.
Now, Carl Sagan said something
very important. He says, yes,
they laughed at Christopher Columbus.
Yes, they laughed at Edison,
but they also laughed at Bozo the clown.
You have to,
you have to be fairly
confident that there's,
there's a there there because you
might end up just being bozo the clown,
in which case they're right to be laughing
at you. It's a matter of subtlety.
I think there's a there there and I'm,
every day I meet more
astonishingly intelligent
people who have fallen down the
same rabbit hole as me in exactly the
same way and have come out of the other
side transformed and have decided to
dedicate their life or part of their
career, or at least the focus,
their energy, their passion,
their work to seeing how far we can take
this little experiment because we all
realize the simple equation underneath
it. Well, there could be nine wrong,
I lose some money and some
of my time if I'm right,
we're going to change the world.
It's a simple as that,
and if I'm wrong, nobody gets
hurt. The people who got into this,
they understand the risks. This is
fringey stuff. This is out. There you go.
Invest all of your retirement
savings in Bitcoin, you're an idiot.
You're going to lose a lot of money.
That's not how you do it,
but the people investing their blood,
sweat,
tears and knowledge and passion and
enthusiasm into this. If they lose,
they've had a fun ride. I'm
enjoying this, but if they're right,
we're changing the world.
Well, I don't the question of
whether or not there's a there there.
I don't think that's a valid question.
There's unquestionably there, there.
It's already there.
We can say that now. A year ago it was
really hard to even make that argument.
Well, now you can say it. Now you
can say it. Now you've got paypal,
Nike by Dell Computer.
If you can use bitcoin,
you send off and then you get a laptop
and then your online with this laptop.
You've got this laptop from bitcoin.
There's a there there, that's a there.
It doesn't matter how many
Phd's in economics, right?
Very long papers telling me it's not
money. If I get a laptop in the mail,
it's money.
It's a there. Yeah, there's
no question about it.
If you use bitcoin to get an escort and
the escort soon as that website is up
and available right now,
it's not to me and refresh all day.
When that website comes online,
Brian will be one of your biggest
evangelists come on right now.
I'm sure you look at Brian
like, ah, this is crazy.
Fuck that Joe hangs out with you.
We'll have a new found respect for him
and his ability to spread the knowledge
and power of Bitcoin once these escorts
sites go up because then things will
change. Like rub maps,
40% of all rub maps.
Customers go to rub maps because of
Brian because they found out about Brian.
I have a serious point to make about
that and I don't want to minimize what
you're saying. Please do. I
wouldn't, I would never imagine.
Um,
the ability to control your money
in a way that is entirely personal.
The fact that you can
memorize a bit coin address,
the fact that you can control that money.
The fact that no one can take it from
you in that industry is an incredibly
empowering process because it would
actually allow the women who are in that
industry to get the value of what
they're doing instead of being exploited
mostly by men and mostly through violence.
So surprisingly enough you can make
a very strong argument that the,
the self determination and control
aspect of bitcoin has a very significant
empowering effect in that space.
You can't get robbed at knife point from
money that's sitting on your wallets
with a pin number or that's being
transferred to an a service that you don't
have access to and your
pimp can't steal your money.
It's a very good point. It's a
very good point. And you know,
not getting deep down into the rabbit
hole of social norms and why laws exist in
the first place in what is and not
empowering to any person takes on any job.
And it's our societal constructs that
make it illegal in the first place.
Manage a woman should be able
to do whatever she wants,
including giving massages or kicking men
in the balls for money. I mean, there's,
there's women that do
that. I mean, there's a,
there's a valid fucking job
to that. There's, there's a,
an occupation trick. They, there's,
there's not just one of them. I mean,
there's thousands of them all across
the country. Maybe even more than that.
I mean, I don't know how many dominatrix
there are, but I've met a bunch of them.
Well, you'll like this story. Um,
the idea of money is not an idea
that just exists in humans. In fact,
money exists in every culture
and is created by every culture,
even by children.
Toddlers creates money spontaneously as
a cultural expression when they don't
know what money is.
They'll trade rubber bands and wooden
blocks and things like that. But in fact,
it's an idea that even goes beyond humans.
You can teach primates what money is.
You can teach them the idea that abstract
token can be exchanged for value. So,
for example, they've done
studies where they teach, she's
in my act 2009 talking monkey's in space
had a whole bit about chimps. Shannon's,
they'd touch chimps,
manned orangutans.
The first thing they did
is they emailed Trump.
Chimps took the mail chimp's
money and fucked him. Right? So
is that two most traded?
Well,
I would say the three most traded
commodities in the world, our food,
sex and recreational narcotics,
they have been the three most traded
commodities in the world since the
beginning of time.
The accusation is that Bitcoin is used
to buy drugs or by sex is a ridiculous
accusation on its face. If it
couldn't be used to buy those things,
arguably it's not money because,
and the thing that cannot be used to
buy the three most traded commodities in
the world is not money.
The point is that money represents the
buying habits of the population using it.
If you wanted to see
mainstream values in Bitcoin,
wait until bitcoin becomes mainstream and
then you will see mainstream values in
bitcoin. It's as simple as that, you know?
Well, it's about personal freedom
when it comes to any form of pleasure.
When people enjoy,
whether it's the pleasure of having
someone cook your meal for you,
the pleasure of having someone
give you a back rub. I mean,
all those things are legal because
it's a, it's a skill. These are,
these are, these are services
that people provide to people.
We just have this weird idea of deciding
what is and isn't acceptable as far as
a service. And as far as I'm
concerned, everything should be legal.
If it's not harming someone,
if, if sex is legal free,
if it's legal for a woman,
and it should be for a woman to go
into any bar and choose a man that she
decides to have sex with, asked the guy
you want to fuck, and the guy goes, yeah,
and then she takes him home and has
sex with them. That's totally illegal.
But if money's exchanged,
somehow, that woman is a criminal.
That we live in a crazy world we live in.
We were insane and we're
only insane because of these,
these echoes of the puritanical values
of the dip shits there were dressed up
like pilgrims and got on fucking wraps
and floated over here from Europe.
It's,
it's,
it's an even crazier idea to say that
you're going to control social interaction
and behavior, not by controlling the
act or by making the act illegal,
but by making the transaction
of money itself illegal.
It's controlling the money is a very
dangerous road down which if we go,
people will use it to control all kinds
of other behaviors that perhaps they
shouldn't, that they're
lies. Totalitarianism.
Here's the points in the fact that
bitcoin can be used for these kinds of
activities is not something
special about bitcoin.
All money can be used for
these kinds of activities.
What is special about Bitcoin is that you
can remove violence from the equation.
In many ways.
The reason people buy drugs online is
because you can't get stabbed over TCP IP.
And that is a very callous
and throw away quip to make.
But it is true fundamentally if you
remove violence from the equation,
that increases the value.
And so that's why people use this money.
That's what's special about bitcoin is
that it allows individuals to retain
control and it removes the possibility
of violence. I think a that's a good
feature. It's a huge feature.
Listen man, we're out of time.
Thank you once again for illuminating us.
And you know it's funny you said the
first time you came on they will,
you'll be on in three months or four
months and things have changed so much and
I keep saying at what point in time
is it going to not change, but this,
it changed more in this
one than the last one.
So come back in a few months again
and we'll figure out what the fuck is
happening then. I Dunno what you foresee
taking place on the horizon, but I'm,
I'm in March, 2015
okay. Jurgen experience.
Let's do it round for,
I'm in, I'm in, I'm in,
I'm full in on Bitcoin, I believe in
it. So to shooter Jennings, so fuck it.
So does tiger direct and Dell
computers and paypal and Brian is still
unconvinced. But once that fucking
escort site is up, he's in, uh,
a n t o n o p on Twitter.
That's um, that sign a. N t.
O. N. O. P. That's very confusing.
It's my first initial and my last name.
Well, you part of your land. Yeah.
That's all I could fit. There's
a lot you got along. That's true.
Because you don't want that.
You use that ad sign.
It eats up a lot of your 140
characters. Thank you very much, sir.
Brilliant talking to you. Oh, we always
enjoy it very much. So. All right.
We'll be back tomorrow. You fucks. So
enjoy. Go get yourself some bitcoin and a,
be cool to each other.
See you soon.
Okay.